but suddenly black is ganging up three
times on this Lone Ranger and he does
play this that's it I thought that
advancing the Knight first kicking the
queen back and then playing C3 would
mean that at least now the pawn is
defended twice only attack twice
everything kind of holds together for
white but uh playing this now is Safety
First chess but uh you are losing the
pawn and remember you are porn up why
you give that material back I'm gonna be
honest though when I suggested C3 I
didn't even realize that the A4 Pawn
will be hanging after this trade but
Hikaru has calculated further uh he
decides to sidestep with the Rook uh but
the eval bar does not approve
is one advantage was the extra pawn and
uh he still hasn't got Castle okay he's
one move away from that but this is uh
it's a very risky way to play I mean
maybe uh black moved the queen now to
try and stop that but that that pawn is
gone so with the pawn not uh being there
any more then I'd assume Magnus is very
happy uh with those last couple of moves
and the evaluation bar also agreeing
that Magnus is doing pretty well here
can we change our picks now David I
think I might pick black now yeah I'll
stick to my guns but not not uh happily
here I really think that this is a key
moment if white gets time to Castle
anything could still happen but if
Magnus does play this key move Queen to
B5 uh highlighted by you that Simon then
hikaru's position does start to creak
a natural looking move C3 but it seemed
that was the big mistake which gives the
pawn back to Magnus Carlsen and right
now a big moment will he find this key
move as Simon is pointing out a key
position in our other match up as well
let's quickly jump over to Maxim against
alireza fuja we did predict that this
will be the matchup with all the
fireworks game one was exactly that and
game two continues to be that look at
that last move putting that Bishop in
front of that H Pawn but you dare not
take it there's a Checkmate on 87.
that's such a cool move it's like
dangling candy in front of a child's
eyes they're so mean Bishop G5 take me
take me but uh Queen to H7 would then be
Checkmate so this bishop is poisoned
Simon looks like an Initiative for white
yeah very interesting idea there and um
I mean these guys they just see so many
tactics you know they they they're all
spotting uh these moves and mile off and
uh it's kind of this position is to do
with Black's better Pawn structure black
has a better Pawn structure but white
has a bit of an attack the White Queen
near Black's King the white Bishops are
sort of hovering over there as well and
with the Rooks coming to the center of
the board it um it's a bit dangerous for
black so how does black the oldest and
David you've also point out another
Potential Threat there the initiative
with white and uh Audi razer's gotta be
he's the one with more danger certainly
in this position at the moment yeah
let's just point that out let's put a
Checkmate on the board if we see one but
Pawn takes Bishop would allow uh Quinta
H7 and the king would be trapped so uh
really flashy move an effective move
huge threat I think the black queen has
to sidestep nothing else to be done here
uh the one move you don't want to play
for example is to block uh the e-file
now you do stop the bishop coming in but
white might now be able to sacrifice on
this Square uh Point Bishop takes Pawn
then this is a very typical type of
sacrifice Checkmate now incoming on H7
so you have to be really really careful
the tightrope here has to be walked by
farugia I think you have to play Queen
to C6 Queen to C7 and there we go the
queen has to move
only way to keep the game going good
call there David just sidesteps with the
queen it gets out of that threat and
what you really want with black here is
to try to trade off the Rooks on the
board take that Bishop out you pointed
out E6 is not a square you want to put
it to you don't want to disconnect your
queen from the King side defense but
Bishop D7 Rook E8 I want to neutralize
the white Rooks once they double up on
the e-line and that last book by maxing
Bishop G5 was a flashy one but if you
just sidestep all these tricks and traps
in the position it doesn't really get
wide anything
I know if black can exchange pieces off
then he's probably going to win the
ending because he's got the better Pawn
structures so right now bringing that
last piece in and I I think we're going
to see right there Tanya just moving the
bishop trying to get the Rooks off the
board it looks it looks very logical uh
way for black to play and uh how how can
white keep initiative alive it's a bit
like the last game though which which
seemed very dangerous uh for one of the
players but the evaluation bar just said
it was equal all along and uh in this
position well I don't know I mean now
White's gotta try and find something but
there's nothing obvious that I can see
here he's got his pieces to the best
squares so how does he improve uh this
position
Black's defending everything so it's not
easy to suggest a move at all yeah we
said it before the show you mentioned it
Simon these two players their Styles
they're both itching to attack they want
to be on the front foot but they're also
great Defenders and uh for us I just
love what he's done the black queen on
the sixth rank which is acting as a
guardian from afar and no way through
for white yeah as soon as you start
retreating in chess in general but
especially in this position with that
fractured Queen Side Pawn structure as
soon as you start stepping back taking
negative decisions things will turn and
uh farouza has set up the idea of a rook
trade maybe at some point you just have
to play it safe have to try and trade
off a couple of pieces if you trade the
right ones
you might be safe with white but there
we go the retreating has begun and uh
fashion took a bit of time we're
normally uh kind of accustomed to seeing
him play instantly every turn amassing
huge time advantages against every
opponent but here he's down on the clock
maybe indicating that he's not happy
with White's position I really like the
way alireza's handle the pressure and it
makes me wonder if Maxine's last move is
actually directed towards not trading
those Rooks and perhaps planting that
dark Squad Bishop on E5 getting the
opportunity to block any trades along
the e-line so Bishop E5 our ideas not
only to block the trade but also some
pressure on the G7 square at some right
moment so this one's still in Balance
let's take this opportunity to check in
with Anish giri who did lose the first
game against janapamnership playing
catch up there uh David is white on an
exchange whoa why this down in exchange
but White's night the night on E5 is
forking both the black Rooks it took me
a while to adapt and to do a count here
white is down a rook for Knight and pawn
but uh is going to win the material back
I think that's guaranteed so it's just a
matter of how to give back the material
which black Rook is going to give up its
life and uh here we go he saves this
Rook to take a pawn I think the most
natural move in the position white will
restore the material balance by taking
black silicon G6 I don't know why Gary
is pausing
and then it's a case of rook and Bishop
versus Rooker Knight which one is
superior and uh Ivanka uh once taught me
that rook and Bishop are better than
Rooker Knight something that I never
really thought about but uh yeah they
tend to combine better and blacks Bishop
is nicely poised nicely placed Black's
Queen side pawns might start to run
quite fast as well
and look at the clock
yeah the clock is uh really not in a
niche's favor again I mean uh often in
these positions well it's just whose
pawns are going to run at the ball
fastest so uh if you have to take the
Rook right at some point and then you've
got to try using your pawns as white but
it's not easy to get a past pawn and the
bishop is a good Defender and a good
attacker so valuation bastard is even
but uh Yan's Chances with the clock as
well uh seem to be much greater
it's the same narrative that we saw in
game one on the clock the 17th piece as
we've been calling it The in the
Champions Chester a niche now under 20
seconds and an end game that's not easy
to defend you pointed out the
combination of the rook and the bishop
especially in this position with that F2
Pawn that is a bit tender uh black can
start targeting it with Rook F3 but the
good news for white is that you can
neutralize that Bishop anytime with a
check on D7 and trade on B6 uh this one
I think it's fair to say if anyone has
Chances with that Bishop on the board
the B4 Pawn week Jan will try to push it
let's use this opportunity to jump back
to our big matchup uh Hikaru Nakamura
with the white pieces against Magnus
Carl so now both players under three
minutes and David before we jump into
this will you do a quick action replay
to see how we got here because it's been
a complicated game from the start yeah
we have a material imbalance right now
the clocks are ticking and the stakes
are higher but let's jump in to show
what happened we left it here uh Queen
B5 the move we suggested was indeed
played attacking this Pawn twice had to
retreat to defend this vulnerable pawn
and suddenly some chaos The Black Queen
steps back out of the range of the White
Knight white retreated himself uh black
tried to crack open the structure and
found his Rook trapped on A4 this was
part of magnus's plan however he took
and gave up his rook and this is the
mess we're left with after Queen to E3
think we just see one more move black oh
black gave a check and retreated his
Bishop to E7 so material count white has
a rook for black bishop and pawn and uh
who do we think is better here White's
King still stranded uh still cut off
from castling you can't Castle through
track here
well to me it's anyone's game without
the evaluation bar I would probably
think that black was doing well but
yeah I I think the king's safety again
has been the same throughout the game
that Black's King has always been safer
than White's King and uh White's got to
get that King to the king side it's
going to take a couple of moves to do
that uh the two Bishops they've got lots
of open diagonals they can move on uh so
so they're looking very strong here as
well and the time situation both of
these players they're the best players
aren't they under you know with no time
that's not really an issue but you've
still got to calculate carefully and
who's got the more danger here what it
has to be uh in this position uh White
who's in more danger grabbing the pawn
though and Magnus has got to show an
idea it is another Pawn very sharp game
if Hikaru loses this game well I can't
see him coming back in the match so he's
just got to make sure he gets some kind
of result out of this one now yeah uh
he's calling the bluff here Hikaru
Nakamura he's just taking all the
material and saying okay you try and
attack me you try and check make me I'm
just gonna kind of Bank it and okay
Magnus takes the opportunity to play a
rook to B8 looks very natural a pin but
the evaluation bar reacts and says
Hikaru now has a bigger big Advantage if
he plays the most natural move in the
position if White's King just kind of
vacates the first rank like we've been
hoping for uh kind of asking for for a
long time connect the white Rooks that's
the reason castling is so strong in
chess in general you connect the Rooks
and uh suddenly what's material
advantage might start to count yeah I've
got I've gotten through you Simon here
the first one that came to my mind after
seeing magnus's Rook be it is Queen to
E5 I'm talking a mate on G7 and a double
attack with the Rook can be it what's
going on after Queen E5 yeah I fought
exactly the same I mean queen E5 crates
are Fork on the board you tap The Rook
uh you attack the pawn here I'm assuming
that black can throw in a check now
maybe Queen A5 is is a way to uh cause
the black the white king some trouble
here where does the white king go all of
a sudden if the white king goes to F2 uh
then at the worst case Black's Queen can
slip in with a check or take the pawn so
there's a couple of Road testing options
so it's just this check on the side of
the border that that saves black in in
this position yeah it's really hanging
by thread for both sides and uh okay
King F2 instead was played so keeping
this one obviously for later nice double
attack spotted there and uh definitely
on both players Radars as well I just
don't see how Magnus keeps the
initiative maybe he was banking on a
move like Bishop to C2 attacking this
white Rook but this idea that you
mentioned Tanya Queen to C3 would now be
a double attack hitting the bishop and
hitting this Checkmate uh from afar I
think Magnus might have let it slip and
suddenly Hikaru with all the extra
material and look at that bar react
again Queen to C4 another inaccurate
move by uh the world number one and this
is a great chance here Cara he's got a
he's gotta take this game now with such
a big uh Advantage I mean he hasn't got
much time he's got 47 seconds still
incredibly complex we can see the
evaluation bar but the players obviously
are not sure uh who's doing what here
and uh what is White's move what is the
killer move head it must be a good move
for white in his position that's a big
question the one thing one thing that I
want to point out is that Queen E5 is
still not possible because of a check on
C2 and I think this was the move that
you were you were looking for coming in
with that Rook onto a temple attacking
that Queen and now that the C2 square is
guarded I was again looking at the idea
of Queen E5 but he falls back with the
queen to D2 because the bishop on C2 is
pinned do you just Spin and win here I
think you do you pin and you win that
black Bishop suddenly the black Bishop
on C2 is immobilized you cannot move it
the black queen would drop off and you
can take a pawn with Czech white C Pawn
is up for grabs but the white king
notice how it's shuffled across the
safety is going to park itself on G2 and
all of the remaining white pieces are
working they're coordinated Magnus gives
a check the white king does move
could this check have be been blocked by
White's Bishop as well maybe and Magnus
gives up his queen queen C3 now yeah you
still have Bishop to our face still have
Bishop to fa I mean uh this looks
horrible I mean your car has got the
extra Queen but
um Magnus is trying to do that famous
thing where she uh does quite often now
get a blockade of somehow on the king
side but white has all the winning
chances the queen is very strong and
when you're playing against the queen
you need to get your pieces coordinating
and I don't think the black pieces are
coordinating a toy Queen C1 is is going
to be a move there's many ways you can
attack those those Bishops now maybe
Queen C1 is is one of those moves uh I
suppose there's a check though in A2
you've just got to be accurate here
there is a check there is he still alive
here he's still alive but Magnus is
really struggling to keep things
together look at those black bishops now
they're skewered against each other on
the C file the valuation bar going up
again maybe the best bet is to just give
up the black Rook here take White's
Bishop off the board and you'll try to
defend with two Bishops against the
White Queen but I I don't know about
Magnus believing fortresses uh I don't
believe in that one
two Bishops versus queen will be a tough
Fortress to pull off Rook takes Bishop
is the move that David suggests a big
question here for Magnus you can give a
check with the bishop to F5 but white
simply pushes the pawn again attacking
both the Bishops at the same time Magnus
Carlsen in big trouble he does go for
your idea David sacrificing the rook and
now it's all about is this a fortress
very strong I've never seen a position
like this before where you've got two
Bishops you've got the poor Magnus there
look at him he's he's gesturing uh with
his hand there what's he saying and uh
did it was it we have a result really it
just he played King to G2 and it ended
in a draw what I am shocked why a draw
what happened Hikaru giving up any
winning chances it's only white who can
win black just has to sit and wait and
hope to draw but that's bizarre that's
the ultimate respect isn't it to to
offer a draw in a position where you're
a queen up this makes no sense uh you
might as well play on a little bit
possibly it's a draw uh but why why is
he even thinking about offering a draw
throw the H Pawn try to use your pawns
you might as well play on uh I've never
seen the car do that before and you've
got no risks in the position you can
play this position forever this is
absolutely shocking and the one player
who fighted out the land is Hikaru
Nakamura we see him reacting there
um I'm shocked at his decision to
actually offer a draw after moving the
king
yeah I mean it's uh I I don't know why
he didn't play on there very strange
decision and you can see Magnus was
shocked as well at the end Magnus was uh
he just left wow he was also like what's
going on why did he offer me a draw I
mean yeah thank you Christmas has come
early I'll take the draw thank you very
much and uh amazing yeah very shocking
and David you get these chances against
Magnus you have to take them you have to
play this out till the end yeah unless
your name is Hikaru you nearly never get
a chance against Magnuson uh especially
when you're one point down in the match
if you he was ahead or if the scores
were level you can understand Nakamura
trying to conserve energy but there he
could have tortured Magnus forever and
he could have played 100 move game 200
move game uh my favorite and uh yeah
still some chances very decent chances
of winning but in the end a draw they'll
have two more games today and uh we do
zoom in on this one instead manager off
against Dennis lazovic let's do a quick
count black is upper Pawn key moment
opposite color Bishops however do lend
themselves towards drawing uh Tendencies
and big dialogue keep his Rook on the a
file The Rook in the corner is attacked
right now to see Playbook A6 for K7 but
abandon the eighth rank or does he move
that black Rook away and I think we'll
see a draw instantly if white captures
that black apron uh it's a key moment
Dennis latvik has to weigh up the pros
and cons the risk involved in playing
for a win yeah uh and meanwhile Jana
panaji has taken a huge lead in his
match against anishkiri winning the
second game as well is turning out to be
a bit of a nightmare thought for Anish
who now needs to win game three on
demand to keep the match going and this
one in Balance opposite color Bishops
with that a pawn still giving plaque
some chances
yeah it just comes down to what David
said can black play like Rook A7 here
and play for a win or Rook A6 and uh if
he can he's having a big think about
this he should do then the game goes on
and uh I mean white gets very active
here The Rook Can Come Thou and black
has to block with the bishop if that
happens I I can't see a follow-up here
though in this position and the the
Blackpool may may just become a queen
um so uh yeah I mean this does this
seems to be all right so what does white
play If The Rook goes to A7 maybe we
have to go back and have a look at that
one so it looks like the back rank is
the weak point but there might be
something else lurking in the position
here maybe yeah Rook uh just Rook A1
just try to win the pawn back right uh
could be the simplest way to play
yeah and uh if for example The Black
Queen tries to use B4 I think you can
just repeat the position just keep
hitting the black queen which is stuck
defending this Pawn next to her if she
ever moves to a safer Square then Bishop
takes pawn and it's just completely
symmetrical this game will end in a draw
he does play Rook A7 Dennis lazovic he's
trying to tempt mamajarov into playing
the active Rook B8 check but this would
be a huge mistake as we saw with the
evaluation bar a moment ago Rook check
just blocked and black will win this
game with the pawn uh on uh A4 so okay
come a major of control the Temptation
and just play Rook A1 not easy in a
rapid game uh he does have attacking
instance after all exactly dude I think
that's the big Point here right not easy
in a rapid game and for a player like
shark who's always looking for these
aggressive ideas but he needs to fight
that Temptation not go in for the line
with the check but immediately just
neutralize Black's a pawn which would
end the game in a draw but he doesn't
wow I mean this is one of the problems
that Shacks play he he gets a little bit
too ambitious and the this move I mean
it kind of seemed like an option but
what's his follow-up if the queen just
moves away somewhere you've got to have
an idea behind your brighten your moves
and a very logical move played in the
game and he moves his work back now
maybe you just missed Rook A1 and uh
Dennis now what Bishop A4 is a track it
is a threat so he's got to find a way to
deal with that one here
maybe Queen A6 was the move and okay I
think we'll see a draw after the bishop
Retreats white does take a pawn and the
Queens come off but missed opportunity
for Dennis lazovic I think he did have
opportunities manager of playing really
risky chess there but now the game will
fizzle out towards a draw
yeah with that a pawn captured it is
been so impressive to see Dennis fight
in these uh uh big boy matches against
the very great in the chess world
including in the Julius bear generation
cup and he keeps the match in Balance
against chakri armamedarov
yeah this is definitely a draw and yeah
I mean there were missed opportunities
these are kind of things when you sort
of see the likes of Hikaru and uh Magnus
they don't generally miss those
opportunities as much uh that's why
they're sort of at the top of the top
um this is kind of a Dennis position is
that you're not going to get more solid
than this and uh a draw now being agreed
there yes fighting Chester but the shark
finding a way out and this one and uh in
a draw while this one was peaceful every
other match has been absolutely filled
with fireworks in this round to David
and I'm gonna throw it back to you once
again what was the standout moment from
game two oof I think we have to go into
that uh match between Magnus Carlson and
Hikaru Nakamura just to explain the
drama that we just saw and the shock uh
that uh was met with that draw offer it
was here Hikaru had a winning Advantage
he'd nicely pinned the black queen and
the black bishop and this move should
have clinched it quantity to Queen takes
C5 and Hikaru would have won on the spot
if he had met this check with a block
Bishop to D4 hitting the black queen
hitting the black Rook maybe what he had
missed that was that Rook d8 would have
been met by Rook to B8 deflecting the
black Rook from the back Rank and next
move feasting on the black queen in the
end we saw some drama but this was the
final position White Queen facing two
Bishops and we are shocked that Hikaru
offered a draw he could still have
played on trying to push these pawns at
the right moment and the game would have
continued a long time in the end a sigh
of relief for Magnus Carlson has this
been the most shocking end to a game
that we've seen this season I think so
definitely yeah I mean especially a draw
office the most shocking drawer for I
think we've had in the champions tour I
mean uh when you've got no chance to
lose the position you've only got
chances to win you play on it doesn't
matter I mean might be a draw in the end
but uh you gotta you gotta try and win
right that's your idea so very shocking
uh draw there a very surprising decision
there by Hikaru Nakamura which means
that he's still playing catch up in his
match against the Magnus Carlton going
into game three the score is level
between the two Frenchmen meanwhile
Anish Gary in a nightmare situation with
a two-point deficit has to win game
three on demand Dana slazovic the 16
year old holding his own once again
against uh one of the best players in
the world chakra Mama dear Evan was a
big game 3 action is coming up an action
does continue There is big news for our
torch Community do not miss out this sub
Temple to the end of this month claim up
to 30 off on all new Subs on Twitch
subscribers getting access to exclusive
break time content during broadcast
unlock new cool emotes and score and add
free experience on chess.com don't miss
out on this deal the September deal uh
subscribe now on Twitch and of course
game three action will continue as we go
through day one of the AI cup we will be
back with all the action in just a few
moments foreign
[Music]
today
everyone loves playing chess and
everyone loves chess club
but there's also a time and a place for
playing all your favorite games
hey we're trying to have a lesson here
you need to get out of here recently
more kids have been playing chess than
ever in school but sadly we've learned
that they may not always be playing
chess at the most appropriate time
while it might be sometimes okay to grab
a game between classes or if your
teacher gives you permission and hasn't
given you an assignment it's not okay to
be playing chess in school when you
aren't supposed to and chess should
never come between you taking your study
seriously and cooperating with your
fellow students and teachers
just over the board or on the phone is a
great way to spend time with friends but
let's make sure that this school year we
don't let too much chess happen
focus on your school because chess.com
will always be there when class is over
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
can we get some other letters please
what's wrong with it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you can find your local group Take the
Lead grow the community at meetup.com
chess and throughout this event we will
be talking a lot about AI technology
throughout this final regular event and
test.com continues to revolutionize
chess bringing the latest and greatest
to chess fans across the world and we
caught up with some of the chess.com
stuff who is behind all these great
developments who make all this
technological advancements possible in
the Chess World
hi my name is Dylan Rittman I'm a
product manager here at chess.com
working on game review hey I'm a Dodge
coats I'm a tech lead on the so-called
core chess team which is largely
responsible for game review well it
depends on your definition of AI
um
certainly by some definition yes it's
all over the place game review coach
Bots I think some colleagues who work on
Fair play as well all try to take into
account these kind of artificial
intelligence it's when producing ways
that we can help you get better at your
chess and detect cheaters on the website
and a few other different places on the
site as well
our products at chess.com are always
geared towards helping kind of the
average user of chess.com get better so
if you go to game review you'll see
coach walk you through kind of the key
moments of your game and
he can be very good at pointing out the
Tactical mistakes that you may have
missed or found during the game and
obviously a few of those brilliant moves
that you can try to get every now and
then the coach Bots are a new product
that are part of our play versus
computer Suite where you can actually
play against coach and he can walk you
through the game and in real time maybe
point out hey there's a tactic in this
position be sure to be on the lookout or
hey you kind of missed a move back there
that would have given you a crushing
lead but don't worry imma give you
another chance here and so by using
coach real time while playing the game
it can be a really valuable tool and
learning as you go and getting better at
chats
sure so for um for a human-like play it
makes a lot of sense one of the key
features of such uh of human-like play
is that they have plans and they seek to
execute plants one of the issues that
you that you face if you try to
um implement this in the in the in the
old-fashioned way so to speak is it's
very difficult to capture plants
um so that's one that's one case where I
could see that's totally finding great
uh great use in these these newer
techniques obviously it feels like a
natural fit to use these large language
models in game review that literally has
a virtual coach trying to talk to you
and walk you through various moves but
what we've noticed in kind of
experimenting with these language models
is that
it's a well-known problem that they're
often just ever so slightly wrong but
the problem is when it comes to chess
the lying between being right and wrong
about a chest move or a chest position
is often really subtle and so a lot of
the work we've done developing game
review kind of without these new AI
tools is actually much more accurate and
much more correct in identifying what's
important about your chess move but
looking to the Future it would be really
cool to kind of combine the tech we've
already developed here at chess.com with
some of these new large language models
to kind of get the best of both worlds
and that's definitely something we'll be
exploring in the future as one of the
many projects that the team's working on
we really hope you've enjoyed this
discussion we're always working hard to
make chess more understandable and using
both new and old forms of AI is always
going to be a big part of that thanks so
much
[Music]
whether you're an advanced chest fan or
chess player or a newer chess audience
so many cool features on chesscom using
AI to help you improve your chest game
review is definitely one of my favorites
uh and right now we've got some of the
big favorites of the Chess World
fighting it out in the AI cup including
the two the very best with a matchup
against each other Magnus Carlsen with a
bleed against Hikaru Nakamura a shocking
game to this decision by Hikaru which
let Magnus off the hook a little too
soon that could have been a big fight a
potential comeback by Hikaru and there
he is on the screen he's got to do it
all over again and this time he starts
with the black pieces
yeah this time he starts with the black
pieces and the name of the game is
survival for Nakamura if Magnus wins
this one the match is over for today uh
two and a half points will clinch it and
Magnus goes back to that tried and
trusted recipe Knight F3 opening with
the ready opening
um yeah it's served him well in the
first game Simon and we see a repeat you
think Nakamura will be Keen to continue
down that path from game one of the day
um I don't think it will go B6 here I
think B6 is a really risky move and he
has he's changed up his openings here I
mean I I think he's just got to try and
draw this game
um unless he gets some chances of course
and he's got to get uh that last game
out of his mind because he probably put
it on the computer uh engine afterwards
and or you know you could see his
reaction he was very upset with himself
so he's got to distance himself away
from uh what happened there and that
that draw offer what will he play here
though many options he could go into a
king's Indian defense he could play a
pawn into the center here he could try
to play a symmetrical kind of English
position
um but yeah which which one do you think
he will go for
well in difficult situations when you're
down a point when it's really kind of
crunch time where you have to kind of
win uh on demand or at least survive
then go back to what you know best
King's Indian he's famous for it it's
all right Simon yeah and that was how he
kind of Rose through the ranks to the
top of World Chess he played the king's
Indian and he doesn't employ it that
much these days that's the uh one it's a
very risky opening so you know we're
talking about G6 here at favorite
opening of Bobby Fisher Gary Kasparov it
can get very sharp there and he has
played it I'm really happy to see this
move it's very exciting and Magnus
playing in the center so we could get a
main line King's Indian defense and uh
I'd always been interested to see what
Magnus has against the king's Indian
defense here he's going to have we have
the main line this is great to see
really exciting feel you salivating
Simon how excited I am really excited I
mean I love the kings in defense I mean
the computer uh the evaluation generally
says that uh uh black is struggling in
this opening but it's a really
counter-attacking openings so you can
see White's Pawns in the Middle look so
scary they're taking over the middle of
the ball but black has all these
counter-attacking Jabs with his pawns
and often later on he can generate a
king side attack so what will he play
here the main line Maybe
that is uh the big question so no more
kg Queens Indian defense by Hikaru
Nakamura he goes for the ultra shop
kings Indian and we are in for a
classical fight there we see Hikaru
developing the night this one's going to
be a big battle given the Mad situation
that's what he needs and in this matchup
also Anish giri needs to create his
chances with the black pieces Jana
vanishi needs just to draw to wrap up
the match in three games and he starts
with white he plays the king spawn
opening this is going to be a tough one
for a niche
especially with the black pieces I mean
uh you you he his style is not really
aimed at winning with black I mean most
of the top players Styles they they
don't take too many risk so he had to go
for the Sicilian and uh be very
interesting to see what Lonnie goes for
Bishop B5 checks Cillian one of the one
of the safest variations there
and after I just wondering are we
talking about yarn needing a draw he's
just switched off the lights in his room
is he already getting ready for the
match uh about to get over what's going
on there getting ready for bed so
draw this one get some sleep right so we
should mention it's been a long day for
Yan he was actually in action in another
tournament earlier today he's playing uh
in the levitov chess week I believe in
Switzerland and uh yeah he's I think
played five games against world-class
opposition earlier today before he even
started this match against Niche so yeah
he's ready for bed he's ready for sleep
he wants this game to be lights out and
uh he wants to take it here and now but
we've seen the trade of Pawns it's
another Bishop B5 check Sicilian as you
mentioned Simon and it's a repeat almost
of the game they had earlier
game one was also this bishop B5 check
Sicilian uh slightly different setup
there but Anish he needs to improve he
needs to get that win and On Demand
against this Rock Solid Pawn structure
for white it's going to be an uphill
snuggle yeah it's very hard to get some
Dynamic chances here because uh you're
lacking a lot of space but you don't
have many like really cool ways to break
out so uh yeah I agree with you David
this is gonna be very tough to just
create any chances here
and you've got a chance to win a Magnus
Carlson signed t-shirt on our screen is
the puzzle of the day and you can send
us your answers on Twitter using the
hashtag chess charms to win
the Magnus Carlsen signed t-shirt and uh
I think we're gonna have that up it's
right here Simon you know oh the other
way around oh okay is there the
signature is there and there's one on
the back as well at the bottom it's a
cool t-shirt you can't wash it though
unfortunately so because you don't want
to get rid of magnus's uh signature but
frame it it'll be worth millions one day
it will and that's the puzzle that you
got to solve and right now we've also
got action on the other birds there's a
niche Gary and this one thinks Ponders
how to create his chances Maxim Russia
lagrav against alireza ferrugia is still
a level match both games ended in a draw
but the chess itself was anything but
peaceful yeah anything but peaceful
we've got to commend these players for
playing such accurate chess such
fantastic chess but also Dynamic
aggressive play and while talking of
aggression the Sicilian night off it
doesn't get much more uh kind of yeah
fighting than this Simon it doesn't no I
mean and MVR is like the uh the leading
expert but he's quite predictable he
nearly always plays this opening and oh
I love it we're getting Queen side
castling here this is going to be very
exciting where does the black king go
and black doesn't worry about the moment
black starts counter play straight away
so uh one of the sharpest uh and most
tactical openings you can you can
possibly hope for so uh yeah gonna be a
great game
can be a fantastic game and you can see
how well these two players know this
opening all the details or the nuances
because they're playing at Breakneck
speed both players with more time than
they started the game with and we're
already at move 14 in a wild opening
white King on the queen side Black's
King in the center we're gonna see pawns
thrown towards each other
um it is very similar maybe if not
exactly the same as their first game of
the day but uh yeah Still Fighting Chess
guaranteed yeah I think it looks like a
repeat here this is where um I think
white took the knight at some point and
then black recaptured with the pawn as
well
um so this uh this is following that
game which was which was Dynamic but
pretty equal all the way through there
hasn't been anything between these two
players right I mean they're they're
just blow to blow so far and I don't
know this could be an Armageddon match
certainly I feel
is it surprising to you that version
kind of blitzed into this position first
15 moves identical to their game early
in the day and then paused uh he has
played a different move though I think
he has yeah another aggressive move just
trying to create some play
um against the center and potentially on
the king side a very normal break and uh
now mvl is uh thinking uh he must have
looked at this move at some point I
would have thought at least
on Maxine boss shadowgrav has been on a
fiery Farm the last couple of months
with his performance at the Tata steel
chasing their Blitz and making it
through to the semi-finals in the SCC
right now in the tank after alireza's
last move F5 an encounter in the center
meanwhile our final encounter is also
underway as Dennis lazovic with the
white pieces will take on chakra
mamidarov this matchup also level starts
with the Queen's Pawn we've been talking
about how it will be decisive the player
that gets their kind of position and so
far in this battle it seems like Dennis
has been getting his kind of positions
definitely game one Dennis lazovic
versus uh Shakura mamajarov it was slow
it was strategic eventually fizzled out
to a draw game two again blocked Pawn
structure manager unable to attack in
lazovic had some decent chances uh so
will he be able to uh kind of initiate
that again for a third time look how
solid lasovic is playing his symmetrical
Pawn structure no trades no sacrifices
no drama he's uh just going about trying
to frustrate his opponent I can see this
going to Armageddon as well right I mean
uh this is really quite well I'm gonna
say dull but I mean it's very
symmetrical it's not that dog so all the
pieces remain on the board so it may
well heat up later on but it's uh it's
the kind of position which Dennis likes
playing he doesn't like taking any risk
um he he understands chess so well and
he's going to wait until the middle game
to try and outplay his opponent with
some careful Maneuvers and Shaq just
developing his pieces quite sensibly
here and at least we're getting some
dynamism in the position at the moment
but it's still far away from when we get
a break in this one meanwhile a lot of
action in the Magnus Hikaru match up
let's go straight back to the battle
between these two greats Magnus taking
on Hikaru
with
the white pieces and uh
wow and that one as we will bring it up
shortly right now chakra is lining up
the bishop and the queen trying to get
that Bishop to H3 to trade off the light
Square Bishops uh but let's jump to our
Maki matchup Magnus against Hikaru and
an interesting Pawn structure there we
keep talking about Bond structures
because they really are the soul of the
position determining the play where the
players play which side they play on and
also who has the advantage we see a
double Pawn on the A-line for Hikaru but
in compensation he's got the long-term
Bishop there yeah long-term Hikaru has
decent chances short term it's all about
whether Magnus can profit from Black's
kind of fractured structure and there is
a hull a big hole in Black's camp that
Magnus will be aiming towards angling
towards with his Knights uh so I think
we have to jump in just a quick action
replay of what's happened uh this is the
current position we left the game around
here black struck out in the center and
Magnus uh was happy after an attack on
the black queen to Simply uh kind of
trade off in the center the fighting
move here would have been stepping
forward proper King's Indian style where
black would attack on the king side
white on the queen side but Magnus
remember he's leading in the match so he
takes the safe option and queen to see
one really sneaky lining up on this
diagonal trying to kick back the Black
Knight next move and this is how we got
that structure Pawn to C5 a sacrifice if
the Black Knight takes this Pawn then
white is doing pretty well after Knight
to D5 hitting this pawn and unleashing
an attack against the Black Knight so
instead C6 and a trade and now I think
everything on the king side of this half
of the board looks pretty balanced
pretty uh kind of level it's all about
the other flank and I'm looking at these
black pawns I'm thinking those are ugly
okay Magnus First kicks back the Black
Knight and then centralizes his Rook if
he can somehow maneuver one of these two
knights into the beautiful D6 Square
long-term Magnus is simply winning
it's uh Hikaru of course has three or
four moves to fight against that he
starts by hitting this Pawn
well Hikaru really wants to get I think
is that F Bond ruling is we were talking
about this get that F5 going you've got
the bishop there you want to open up the
position as quickly as possible the
Knight maneuver for white always in the
air Magnus you pointed this at 92-94 get
that Knight onto that D6 square a plan
that has been stopped right now by
magnus's move 98 and F5 is on the board
this is going to get chaotic
yeah this is very very standard idea in
the king's in defense if you if you
can't play F5 as black then the opening
would be complete rubbish but this move
uh is the move that generates loads of
play uh the pawn can storm forwards as
the other Pawns in the king side can uh
the evaluation bar again it nearly
always dislikes Black's position and
these kind of cases but uh black gets
active play it's a very risky opening
and uh it's it's very brave for Hikaru
to play this opening in a game which he
can't lose because it comes with a lot
of risk you know it comes with a lot of
risk we pointed out strategically black
on the queen side suffering uh
short-term and long term but right now
that's irrelevant it's all about whether
Magnus can stem the flow of these black
pawns they're just gonna storm down the
board uh like an avalanche I think you
might have to just take this Blackboard
before it continues advancing uh but
okay there we go a Trader pawns at least
now you've held up uh that kind of Pawn
push temporarily White Queen being on
the same diagonal as the black king a
little awkward pin there for Hikaru and
now another pin Simon this move rooked
E1 it looks like Magnus has lost a bit
of time he's kind of kind of yo-yoed
back and forth with the white Rook but
he's lining up
yeah this this is maybe the problem with
the pawns here that black has they can
be overextended uh they look kind of
dangerous and if black can consolidate
those pawns he's probably all right but
um the the bishop now White's Bishop on
E3 may be just threatening to come in
and attack the pawn in the center again
and make it move again and uh hikaru's
got to be a bit careful here I think uh
his position could implode unless he
finds some very clever moves there yeah
that being said he's up on the clock
three or four minutes
he's got to be pretty happy with the
outcome here Hikaru I think against
anyone else in the world he'd be feeling
pretty confident right now but it is
Magnuson of course long-term strategic
things against Magnus if it ever gets
down to an end game we know who's going
to be the favorite there
um so the stakes are really high for
Hikaru in this double-edged middle game
Stakes are extremely high for Hikaru and
not just Hikaru in division two stakes
are extremely high for big fish for
Vladimir FedEx who is fighting it out
for those tour points to get through to
Toronto he has won his match against
Kosovo so advances to the winners
quarterfinal where he will be playing
against Winston kaima uh and for
federacy the path is clear he needs to
get those 50 tour points by winning
division two needs some results in
division one to go his way to book that
spot and he did have a really big chance
in the planes when he was playing
against Anish giri a winning position
but Anish is the one who won that match
made it through to division one and that
was you have now fighting it out in
division two with a good start and this
one seems to be a good start for Magnus
that last move Rook to E1 also
threatening the bishop jumping onto the
center of the board lining up the
pressure along that E5 Pawn if it's
white to play I would love to play the
move Bishop to D4 right now I'm not only
hitting that E5 Pawn but once you do
advance that pawn to E4 I'm happy to
trade off the dark Square Bishops yeah
yeah good move
very good move here and I'm also
wondering if there were tactics I don't
think quite yet with Knight takes E4 um
getting carried away calculating this
looks very very tempting because
suddenly you're attacking the black
queen and you're lining up on this
diagonal but black does have a nice uh
reply here Bishop to F5 breaking uh the
tension between the queen and uh this is
a pin we'll just see a trade and black
off the dust clears is a piece up it's
key that the Knight defends the bishop
but this is the type of thing the type
of variation going through both players
heads right now
um Nakamura doesn't really want to break
the Integrity of these pawns by pushing
either of them on either of them forward
as Tanya mentioned suddenly here uh
black would lose control over all of the
dart squares for example white doesn't
even need to capture yet or I can just
bring more pieces into the action so he
doesn't want to touch anything
how to prevent this threat Bishop to D4
maybe bishop to F4 as well
I have to play the move Rook to G8 the G
line is open I want to line up my Rook
against your king but I think still the
idea of Bishop D4 is in the air to
neutralize pressure and now also I just
realized once the move the Rook moves to
G8 David your idea after E4 and then you
can sacrifice on e4 so there are a lot
of these tricks that actually exist in
the position E4 94 suddenly becomes game
yeah still uh still some complications
there but very very tempting here for
white and okay Hikaru wanted none of
this drama none of these tactics Rooks
opposite Queens that's the most
uncomfortable situation uh in the chess
game so getting out of the way getting
out of Dodge Queen F7 looks very healthy
uh respect your idea next Tanya if if
black gets time Rook G8 Queen G6 lining
up against the white king and this could
turn
and Simon I'm just thinking still about
what we saw in game two right this is
such a such a gutsy position for Hikaru
to get into and he's somebody who's
really known to take these Brave
decisions over the board he doesn't shy
away from any complications give him an
opportunity and he takes it and then he
gets into this risk-free end game and
then just lets Magnus off the hook
yeah I mean maybe we've been a little
bit harsh I mean it could be possible
that their understanding is well
certainly a lot better than mine and uh
hikara just looked at it and said well I
I'm playing Magnus the best end game
player in the world I can't I can't go
through here I I think he should have
played on anyway I mean you know when
you've got risk-free position let me
rephrase that time and if Magnus is
playing that position with white oh he'd
always play on it reminds me of famous
story of Bobby Fischer Bobby Fischer was
playing uh another strong Grandmaster
and got into the ending rook and Knight
versus Rook which is a draw
um but you have the extra Knight and his
opponent offered him a draw and Bobby
Fisher just said why why would I take a
draw I'm a knight up and of course the
game ended in a draw but you can at
least pressurize your opponents so it
was very strange that decision and uh he
could certainly regret that I mean look
in this position it just seems like
Black's piece is a very stale here
they're not they're not energized so uh
you know it's dangerous dangerous
position and exactly what you said right
you even if the game ends in a draw it's
on your terms you let Magnus earn that
draw by fighting out that defense and
there we know that Kaiser is not happy
with such decisions yeah the goddess of
Chess she punishes people who end the
games too quickly who don't fight to The
Bitter End who don't take uh kind of
principled active aggressive decisions
and yeah Nakamura offering a draw in
that last game if he gets uh eliminated
here or at least pushed down to the
other bracket uh by Magnus winning then
he'll look back he'll think missed
opportunity at least psychologically
playing on uh I mean that's for me at
least the kind of the most pleasure you
could get from chess just asserting your
dominance over the opponent you're
asserting your Authority by kind of
showing them okay I'm the one trying to
win I'm the one trying to win you're
just playing for a draw at the very best
and uh okay we'll see uh kind of history
is of course written by the winners but
Hikari right now it looks like he's in a
bit of trouble on the board I love what
Magnus has been doing he slowly
maneuvered he's taking two moves but
he's brought his Knight around to the
king side White's King much more secure
much more comfortable now and also
Black's King on the diagonal
starting to feel the heat potentially
yeah it is and if the king are just
looking at a line tries to step back so
it moves out of the diagonal I think
Magnus has a very clever idea of
um moving his Knight's side of board
maybe we can show that Knight to H4
potentially here and you know black
would love to mobilize one of those
pawns but you can never move the F Pawn
forwards because you actually get
checkmated here uh or you have to give
up your queen with a very nice
combination of the White Queen coming in
with Checkmate so those pawns they're
they're often like are they strong or
are they hanging this is this is the
question and uh the more this game is
developing the more they seem to be
hanging and they seem to be very very
weak Pawns in the position so uh yeah I
mean it's still problems for Hikaru to
overcome here but he has the time if he
can maintain those pawns he he will be
doing pretty well yeah the problem is
what to do for Hikaru this Rook is kind
of stranded offside disconnected it's
kind of the borders cut in half it can't
join its Army this Black Knight wants to
to kind of vacate the back rank get to
an active post but if you ever move it
away the white Rook will be ready to
pounce Into the Heart of Black's
position remember this square is a nice
little hole and uh pawns will start to
drop so I just don't really see any
productive moves
um of course as we mentioned earlier you
don't want to break the Integrity of
your pawns and the most logical move
stepping out of the eye line of the
White Queen does have its drawbacks as
Simon mentioned some really really
difficult and that is reflected in how
much time Hikaru has been taking over
the last few turns Magnus uh the clocks
are roughly level but Magnus has been
kind of upping the momentum upping the
speed here starting to hint at those
threats as we highlighted as well and
okay the king does drop back I'm
expecting your move on the board Simon
yeah I wasn't sure how he's going to
defend against this move I mean the the
white knight coming in
um and he does play it immediately I
think black's only move is to play E4
here but it looks it looks kind of loose
right okay he's he's just defended his
Pawn in a sensible way but everything is
just hanging on for black here and you
know one wrong move and it's going to
collapse this position
um but is there a way to break through
immediately here and if Magnus actually
is able to convert this one that's just
match over for Hikaru that's a collapse
of the match for uh for Hikaru Magnus uh
in driver's seat right now the bishop
has dropped back to D2 so ideas of
rerouting the bishop to the other
diagonal you want to put it to C3 again
Target that Central E5 Pawn uh trying to
get rid of Black's dark Squad Bishop
things are looking Bleak for Hikaru
right now any King's Indian defense with
the black pieces you want to get to
white skin you want to try to create
your attack but he hasn't been very
successful so far
yeah I just don't see any moves my first
instinct was there's too much pressure
on this Pawn let's try and for example
kick this Knight away but suddenly this
would walk into a beautiful tactic Rook
takes porn and the black queen is
overworked she cannot take this Rook
it's poisoned because of a nice family
Fork here a royal Fork on the king queen
and rook and uh of course if the black
queen takes this Knight as well then her
Bishop would drop and white would have
picked up a very important Pawn so
tactics are working out in White's favor
and normally as a player psychologically
when you're calculating in your head and
things are always working against you
always kind of turning out well for your
opponents suddenly you start to collapse
you panic and Bishop C3 is so annoying
all these dark squared weaknesses uh
towards the black king
yeah King's Indian you want to be
attacking you don't want to be on the
defensive I think you'll move uh from
earlier Simon must be played sooner or
later E4 now or on the next few turns
but then white will of course trade off
the dark squared Bishops and if White's
Knights ever kind of land on F4 that
would be a beautiful position and
strategic domination for white I mean I
can see why Hikaru doesn't want to play
that move because as soon as you do play
that your pawns lose a lot of the
fluidity that they have he'd love to
move the other pawn and try to start an
attack but he can never do this because
the G6 square is just too weak yeah
oh really is he giving up the queen
what's happened here what is happening
here what is randomizing he's gambling
this is going to land with a check I
think this is almost guaranteed at this
point Magnus will give this check the
difference here is not it's not game
over it's not Checkmate because this
time the king can use the G8 Square
which was uh liberated by the black Rook
last turn and he's just giving up
material here he's hoping for Knight
takes Rook potentially because suddenly
he'll take the other night and uh this
black this White Knight has no time to
save itself because there's a nasty
threat of Pawn takes Pawn on F2
evaluation bar still says this is
winning for white or very promising at
least
um but the question here is whether this
white knight can simply move maybe it
retreat if you're feeling ambitious and
brave you might go to the side of the
board I think Nick Nakamura here he's
banking on Bishops F5 a double attack
against the queen and the Knight but
there is a trick there is a trap as
always as we've seen actually a theme of
this game Queen takes sacrificing and a
fork at the end and I think white here
will end up in a very promising endgame
yeah it looks like it because you're
gonna eliminate um black start Square
Bishop but then play uh this bishop C3
right and again it's those pawns that
the Pawns in the center they just seem a
little bit too weak they're hanging
pawns White's work works and the bishop
are brilliantly placed and uh this this
position is kind of collapsing so uh uh
so yeah it's uh I I like that I kind of
like the idea because he's got to take a
risk but he's hot it's hard to get away
with such a move against Magnus Carson
right I mean against me easy but I mean
uh not against Magnus and what does he
play here then I think he's got it I
mean I I'm not sure they're both they're
both disgusting those lines so you know
if you've got a choice between two bad
options what would you go for yeah
um respecting Magnus now to play Knight
H5 he's kind of controlled himself he's
paused here he's calculating but that
line there we go Knight to H5 it's very
linear it's very direct and suddenly
look at hikaru's reaction that H5 landed
on the board he looked away discussed
and he now realizes the bishop to F5
does not work the move he was relying
upon it looked like a double attack but
White's Queen would just capture an F5
and that fork all those kind of traits
lead to a winning end game for white and
that's why the bars got so excited
Hikaru in huge trouble
yeah you can tell from his face that I
mean if this move doesn't work then
um he's going to be at least losing the
exchange but Magnus can can also just uh
move his Bishop take the dot I mean
everything is working well for Magnuson
I don't see Hikaru making it to the
fourth game uh I just can't see how he
can do it here yeah I don't think he'll
make it for the next couple of moves in
this one he does fall back with the
bishop so not allowing the trade on G7
does white have time now to actually
just get greedy with that Rook on f8
Knight f8 is that what you just go for
and ask black to actually show what
compensation you've got
Knight f8 before it's too late
I don't hate uh winning material uh it's
just a question of whether Magnus is
feeling greedy maybe there's something
even better here for white
um still this threat of Bishop to F5 for
black it's unclear whether that's uh
actually possible because of all those
Forks those night checks we were
highlighting a moment ago and uh Magnus
here maybe just wondering whether he can
slow play it keep building up because
those white Knights aren't going away
anywhere anytime soon and Nakamura is
shaking his head again yeah yeah I mean
this is uh I think hikari's only chance
here is White's Knight on H5 is lacking
some squares uh White's night on right
on the side of the board but uh with
careful calculation here uh I mean just
look at White's pieces and look at
Black's pieces blacks pieces they're
hovering on the background they're all
sleeping they can't go anywhere White's
pieces are all developed they're all
active and just for that reason alone
it's uh it's creaking badly for black
that's a good point to make the Knight
on H5 doesn't have squares so white does
get greedy with that Rook on f8 what
Hikaru might be banking on is King afed
and now he's asking questions how are
you actually defending that Knight on H5
I see G4 is a move but I would be a
little hesitant to play that yeah at the
very least Hikaru would get some counter
attacking chances against the white king
evaluation bar has uh of course no fear
of ghosts it says white is just winning
here with the extra material Rook for uh
Bishop but yeah this is what his car is
banking on at least from a human point
of view Magnus would get slightly
nervous here White's King not entirely
safe so a good practical Chance by
Hikaru I like his last move bishop h8
and it has forced Magnus to think but
yeah Knight takes Rook looks promising
Knight takes Bishop looks promising this
Pawn is collapsing uh Magnus sport for
choice and he does go for the material
he does play G4 wow because I'm pretty
sure he's made of AI Magnus Carlson I'm
pretty sure he's uh artificial
intelligence just embodied and uh just
Fearless
we don't want to get there the stock
fish I mean he's been learning from day
one he's been teaching himself learning
from himself yes I mean he just sees
everything doesn't it and uh I mean this
you can see it on hikara's face I mean
he he realizes that it's backfired it
was a risky opening and um it seems I
mean he's just playing so well Magnus
Carlson not just in this match but in in
the last couple of months he's he's uh
dominating everyone pretty much you know
pretty much yeah he does seem
Unstoppable right now chess from another
planet you said AI visual intelligence
it's absolutely insane is the AI that I
think of when you think about that's
what I meant everyone AI I meant
actually insane like his chest sir yeah
and uh okay on passant flashy move there
from Hikaru but white
Zooms in with a check and I think we
will see the final flourishes on this
game white tonight saves itself white is
up a whole exchange and a pawn and
Black's King side in tatters yeah yeah
looks like Magnus Carlson is about to
wrap up his match in just three games
and huge up there then she has already
done it against the Anish giri that game
ended in a draw so Anish Gary is now
down to his last life will go down to
the losers bracket while Jana bombshi
continues in the Winner's bracket Hikaru
Nakamura he continues to play but it's
not just a position you can look at him
and you know that he's feeling hopeless
about his chances right now grabs a Pawn
on the other edge of the board I don't
think anyone cares about that pawn no
look at black skin it's kind of
desperate right I mean if you're in a
bad position anyway you might as well
try to grab as much material as you can
and um but I mean maybe white can now
swing a rook over you just need to
attack the weakened black king here that
black king it's not just that White's
material happens mentioned the black
king is so exposed and
um those Rooks I just think they can
join in the attack probably here might
be something stronger but it looks it
looks horrendous and the Queen instead
this is this is also going to be a
killer blame Magnus and his Queen moves
tell me about a love story yeah she
loves his Queens especially in the
center of the board I don't know how
they always end up on these amazing
squares why it's uh well magnus's Queens
in particular uh it gives a check
Black's Kings sidelined and okay again
spoil for choice and sometimes that
isn't a good thing when you know you're
winning when you have too many tempting
moves magnus's clock as well
um under one minute but of course it's
those Queens again she lines up against
the black king and Hikaru now threatened
with a devastating discover check the
white Bishop hoping to jump out the way
next move and what to do how to defend
you've got to go back with the King
you've got to sidestep any big check
with the bishop King to G it comes to my
mind
yeah King to GA I I can't see much out
much else I mean I I guess whites yeah
and uh Hikaru has played it he's got to
get away from that check and how does
white now finish this off I mean three
pieces attacking against an exposed King
is normally enough but it feels like you
might need one more okay the Knight is
now aiming for a better square and a
rook coming to G3 where the Knight just
came from is also going to be uh
terminal here so uh hikara doing his
best but he's doing his best in a very
bad uh situation yeah Rook D3 Rook E3
huge threats here on the board both of
those white Rooks just need to somehow
swing across to the open G file and uh
any check here will just spell the end
of the game Hikaru is defended pretty
well uh since that kind of flurry of
tactics but it's gonna be hard to
prolong this game further
I think you'll be looking back on that
draw we mentioned it momentum changes we
talked about their rivalry throughout
the last decade or more and uh often
it's just one or two moves that
kind of cost you in these high pressure
situations you said this before David as
well you said that you know when when
you offer a draw when you shouldn't be
uh you know the god of Chess is is
really unhappy right and she will punish
you and that that that is the case here
I mean uh he he should have played on he
had some chance to at least annoy Magnus
he didn't do that and well it's creaking
now it really is freaking Queen F5
played but that doesn't threaten
anything it doesn't save anything and
I'm expecting your uh maneuver here
there we go Magnus plays it instantly
the white Rook swings up and across
and that blackrock's still on it hasn't
made a single move a single contribution
to the game so he's not only done an
exchange but actually playing without
the other Rook as well Rook G3 a big
threat on the board
I won't be surprised if Hikaru just
decides to end the torture here yeah I'm
right here right now Rook G3 and Rook F3
it is a threat just to win the black
queen and uh if you take it you've got
Knight G5 check I I can't I can't see
any any way to defend and let's have a
look on his face is this is this the
moment where he's gonna have to go down
into the lower bracket he's holding on a
little bit more but oh
so they're getting in each other's way
as well those pieces and uh you know
every white piece is piling over
20 seconds each I mean you can still
blunder you might as well play on yeah
we saw some mouse lips we saw some crazy
turnarounds in the speed Chess
Championship final so Never Say Never
Hikaru doing the right thing and uh
fighting on never resigned too early uh
never offer a draw too early either but
this one he's fighting to the better end
the problem is his Bishop disappears and
now 27 might have six
oh but this check could be a killer
Magnus using geometry here loose pieces
drop off the black queen undefended I
think after one more accurate check here
the black king will be forced to a
square the White Knight can jump out the
way the black queen would have dropped
and that's the one Queen z7 check on the
board and Hikaru Nakamura with the shake
of his head resigns and Magnus Carlsen
taking the match in just three games a
dominating performance today and it all
comes down to that game two where Hikaru
did have his shot might not have been
enough but he could have continued but
right now no revenge for Hikaru Nakamura
and this one is still on alireza feruja
trying to Target Maxim's King but also
Maxim lining up against alirez asking on
the queen side and both players
these positions are crazy I mean you
look at these guys games and the
position looks like one side must be
winning but the evaluation buzzer was
like no it's always even you know even I
mean look at it the stuff going on to
both of those Kings David I mean I mean
whites King's gonna attack Black's
King's gonna attack oh there's a lovely
idea there I think that
we had to show that there was a huge
threat on the board momentarily uh just
for that one second uh but of course
defended by Ashley Graf wrote to D3 we
saw it in the Magnus game swinging
across a rook but here there's a deadly
threat if Pawn takes porn uh here not
Magnus farouza would have sacrificed his
queen queen takes pawn and what we call
a lawnmower Checkmate the black king now
cuts on the edge of the board and would
have been trapped but uh maxim of course
not a uh not uh allowing this queen to
E5 prevents this idea because Queen
takes porn now would have allowed a
block from the black queen and black
would have been up a rook at the very
end so who's attacking who it's unclear
whose King is weaker the white king not
entirely safe either a threat was lined
up but black simply advances
chaos chaos but for maxim he can be
happy about those extra two minutes on
the clock in such a position that's
exactly what you need and notice how he
keeps that H5 Bond defended from any
sacrifices from that Rook to G5 a rook
H5 is not possible anymore and B takes
A3 taking that pawn on the queen side a
big threat on the board 10 seconds for
firuja this is not an easy position to
defend with white it's not an easy
position with one hour on your clock let
alone a few seconds it's crazy I mean
queen G do you have to go crazy for he's
called Queen F4 but now Black's gonna
get the chance to attack and I don't
think there's any is there any threats
here Rook takes H5 is potentially a
threat is that right
um I mean it's a way to maybe get a
Perpetual all these games always end in
a draw they're all so crazy uh they
always ended Perpetual check with
correct play and maybe after Pawn takes
Pawn white takes on H5 and it is that
draw though yeah with the air truck yes
with the eight-track yeah that that
would be the idea but I I don't know
maybe do you see it because after you
can just move we recapture with the pawn
so it might not be the threat right now
and Maxine is calculating all these
lines yeah and Maxim has just under two
minutes I think we need a helping hand
from the computer what does uh the
engine suggest here as Black's best move
because we see the evaluation bar
there's only one move that gives the
advantage actually only two moves for
Black Avoid defeat uh but one is very
strong and that's Queen to E1 check and
let's show this on the board Maxime has
to find this anything else and this
could uh completely turn Queen to E1 is
the key move because of geometry again
Queen to E1 if the white king moves then
double attack a check hitting the king
hitting the rook and uh White's Rook
would now be forced to block this check
and no more attack against the black
king I think black would take over and
uh it's crashing through now on B3 but
this is not obvious Quint E1 uh maybe
this would force the White Queen to drop
back and we'd head into an end game and
even that is unclear yeah what a move
that would be if Maxine finds it will he
find it I I think he'll find a question
yeah now he's thinking about a minute
under a minute on the clock and he does
find that Maxim the 2021 World Blitz
Champion precise there
and white has to put the Rook uh stop
the check he would have lost the Rook on
H3 otherwise David there was a big
threat that white had to take on H5 with
Rook G7 coming in earlier and I don't
know if you have a quick moment to show
Simon's idea because that is what Maxime
had to fight against yeah just to show
how strong these players are queen to E1
check the only move if you've taken this
Pawn white would have won on the spot
with Rook takes Pawn uh either black has
to lose the queen and actually get
checkmated or black would have taken the
spawn and a nasty checkmate at the end
here and uh this would have been game
over so huge turnaround potential but
let's go back to the game because uh
it's still equally crazy look at this
white king who's checkmating who that's
the big question well if it's black
small if Queen E1 is game over but it is
blacksmith if anyone Queen C1 you've got
you've still got a defense against the
check and white also has uh that fret of
Rook H5 forcing Checkmate I mean uh so
Queen E1 looks forced and uh you can
attack from before yeah maybe rookie one
as well uh is another option just try to
get another piece and see attack okay I
meant coming down to E1 and uh this this
is looking good uh for black now White's
pieces may be a little bit misplaced
really really playing with fire there
for Ruger he played that move with two
seconds left Rook to see through he's
trying desperately to defend Safeguard
his King but the black queen can simply
move now there are no threats anymore
against the black king and uh if black
can coordinates something all of his
major pieces the Rooks and black queen
all against the white king this should
be over he starts with a check and all
yours has played the last five moves
with two seconds on the clock I have no
idea how he's keeping his composure and
his arm right now but he continues to
fight and not making any blunders any
checkmates on the board Maxine with all
the pressure now targeting that F6 keep
on in White's position
well he's just holding on here isn't he
his back rank White's first rank is so
weak if black can ever get on look at
the king now he's open up the king even
more
rookie rookie one is also winning the
queen this is probably the end here I
don't think there's any way that white
can defend what an exciting game
brilliant game there from mvl incredible
attacking technique by Maxine
barcelograph gets him the point against
who resigns after that last queen move
with multiple threats and there it is uh
Maxim with the win which means that
farouza has to win the final game on
demand it's been an incredible battle
between uh these two players
and while the action still continues in
this amazing battle between uh Dennis
lazovic and Shakira mamidaro and this
one's quite a different position from
the kind of positions we've been seeing
in the map so far yeah suddenly mamajoro
for the first time in this head-ted
encounter has his type of position black
is a piece down but it's throwing
everything at the white king and while
suddenly using some pins here kicking
away the White Queen from the defense
white has to be really careful I think
you have to be a bit cautious about
where you kind of place your queen right
now
wow that white king is living on the
edge Simon this is your type of position
do you think mamajarov is going to break
through well I mean it's a crazy
position isn't it I mean you've got Rook
G8 and queen takes is he offering a draw
now just by moving forward that that
would be uh I mean I would love to try
and play for a win uh in the position
but maybe manager off just decides that
he can't do it but he's got eight
seconds he's got eight seconds and but
then it's now down to 10 seconds we're
gonna find out now is he gonna take the
draw or is he going to find a way to
play on here I think it's gonna gonna
head to a draw
yeah and uh promising position from my
major but he had no time and he repeats
three times we see that position and
chaotic draw but a draw nonetheless and
the score's still tied
that was an absolutely insane game and
finish that we just caught in time
between Dennis last week and chakra so
this match remains level and wow we've
had two matches that are decided already
Jana Palmer Magnus Carlsen taking the
win the match in this one in just three
games
David what was the big moment well
impressive play of course from Magnus
Carlson and Jana pomonishi to win their
matches in just three games but I want
to highlight that breathtaking win by
mvl just uh for the pure drama and that
really rare situation of both sides kind
of with mutual attacks and he lived life
on the edge of Ashley grav the black
king was in trouble earlier as we saw
but it was here that he clinched it he's
going for the white king trapped in the
corner and this first move a sacrifice a
rook sacrifice Rook to C8 if uh we'd see
a capture here and the White Queen
getting too greedy we would have seen a
back rank Checkmate on the first rank
here and uh of course the Clincher after
root C8 we saw was this move Rook takes
rook and uh if Rook takes
Queen's F2 and uh black would penetrate
on the first rank instead he delivers
Checkmate on the second rank game over
with a beautiful attack
it's just amazing play but one of the
most attacking aggressive players of
modern chess Maxine Russell finishing it
in style and this is the storyline so
far we just want more rapid game
remaining Magnus Carlson janapamnushi
have put Anish Gary and hikao Nakamura
down in the elimination bracket while
alireza Maxim alireza has to win the
fourth game to take it to tie breaks
Dennis lazovic chakra mom made out of
continues to be a level match it's
exciting exciting chess and we are also
very excited to announce uh at this
tournament that chess.com is partnering
with browser maker Opera we are thrilled
about this collaboration it's something
for chess lovers everywhere it truly
truly puts the game right at your
fingertips no matter where you are with
some incredibly cool features on the new
Opera chess themed browser so check that
out and we will be checking in with a
game four the final rapid game action
and the other side of this break foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things.com
enchant your pieces with one of two
spells jump or freeze the hairs start
with two jump spells in five free spares
which we charge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spare cash to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a three by
three square area and the pieces in this
area are temporarily Frozen in place
combine your powers of Chess and sorcery
to defeat your opponent
available now on chess.com
September Bots are here and it's time
for a Monumental Clash this Barbarian
might not Crush you on the board but he
certainly can Crush you with the board
king of crushing this giant is a living
Siege Tower usually found in groups
goblins are fond of sharp pointy objects
and other people's pieces
battleheart in Valkyrie might give you a
game once she's done arm wrestling a
Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare lay them all on
chess.com
four years chess kit has had lots of fun
online events but it's finally time for
us to go IRL in real life puzzle
competitions a main event and all sorts
of other fun things to do announcing the
chess kid National Festival
come along you'll need fun Master Mike
there
I'm going to the Chaska Festival I'm
going to the chest Festival
[Music]
introducing the first ever Chester
national festival join us in Charlotte
North Carolina for four days of Chess
festivities including over the board
tournaments and opportunities to meet
special guests like Gotham chess fun
Master Mike and chief chess officer
Danny Ranch the festival takes place
February 16th to 19th and we can't wait
to see you there use the command
Festival in chat to learn more and
register today subscribers stay tuned
for a special message from fun
mastermike during the break
and we are being joined by a very
special guest Magnus Carlton is joining
us in the studio for an interview after
his uh three-game match Victory against
Hikaru Magnus congratulations
yeah thank you
uh and also for the speeches
Championship win and Magnus my first
question to you is that when you want
SCC you said you were happy with the
result but not happy with the score line
or wanted to assert more of a domination
did you feel that you were more
successful doing that today
yeah but this is a much smaller sample
size so
it doesn't you know uh
you cannot lay the smackdown in the same
in the same way sort of uh but with that
said of course uh the story today was um
was excellent
it's about as good as you can
uh well it's about as well as you can
you can do of course
two and a half out of three but that
second game Magnus uh at the end we were
surprised by how quickly it ended uh
Hikaru agreeing for a draw there did
that surprise you a little bit uh do you
think that was premature
yeah the second game was just horrible
um
I missed so many things there
um I I like the way he played the
opening
um enterprising and surprising but I
think I I reacted fine and then at some
point he should sort of just reconciled
with that the position was
was more or less equal
um and I I immediately realized that the
way he played later
um
was way too risky but I couldn't
find a good solution and then I just
started messing up
um but clearly the worst move was uh
Rook B8 because I'd simply missed King
F2 and then I can almost
I felt like I can almost resign because
I don't have any threats anymore and
he'll just consolidate and yeah
afterwards I was shocked when he went
Queen day too
um I mean of course it wins by my queen
but it gives me significant drawing
chances and now that I was just trying
to to hold on
um I wouldn't say I was either
happy or particularly unhappy to
enter the position with
the queen against two Bishops
um I did feel
that it's probably closer to to draw
than to win frame especially considering
that there's a there's a famous game
Paul guyevsky against gettler I think
where pulgeevski won with three against
three on the king side and uh
symmetrical and queen against two
Bishops uh I assume that
the way it is
especially since my Bishop can come to
uh can come to D5 and get set anchored
Square there I assume that it's
that it should be a draw but
um yeah I guess he was just frustrated
uh and didn't want to try but
I think
yeah it's pretty clear that you're just
giving away Equity there for for no
reason
Magnus that's pretty impressive pulling
up a game from 1968 just out of the
memory bank there but I just want to ask
about your Tweet uh before the game
started talking about revenge not being
served at all
no yeah I didn't know that okay
I better not ask moving on Simon hi yeah
thanks I'm Magnus I mean uh do do you
consider like Hikaru your main rival now
in sort of at least online chess and uh
um I don't know about over the board
chest but online chess at least
so I think there are in terms of Rivals
there are there are tiers and so there's
the first tier is like no Rivals and
then a little bit
after that is the current so it's
definitely the
um
he's definitely the second after no
Rivals I would say
uh and
Magnus uh SCC finished on Friday you
started this event on Monday did you get
some time to celebrate your big SEC win
uh no I haven't really celebrated
um
you know I had the tournaments
today also I've been feeling a little
bit under the weather so I'm sure they
had time to to do that but
yeah no just trying to prepare for her
today and uh more or less than
or get in shape all right well Magnus we
hope you recover quickly and we look
forward to seeing you back tomorrow in
action
thank you thank you Magnus Carlson
winning his match against Hikaru in
three games and this means some changes
in their fullest match stats right here
with a big accuracy in this match on 90
percent accuracy by Magnus 86 for Hikaru
that game too Magnus was pretty
confident that he would be able to hold
that position pulling out that random
1968 memory that you were talking about
yeah for anyone at home who wants sir to
check out that game left poligoyevsky
against Ephraim Geller from 1968. Magnus
has it all up there it's crazy he's
another level I'm telling you absolutely
insane that is
there as well that was like you
obviously know the game very well as
well what can I say I've studied it all
before
and after the fact that he had no idea
about the tweets that means someone's
running his Twitter
all right while the action is still on
on the other matches uh Jana partnership
has won his uh battle against Anish giri
he continues in the Winner's bracket but
Maxine vashiella Graf still has a job to
complete here alireza fuja with black
has to find his chances the kind of
games the kind of fights that we've been
seeing in this battle so far those
chances will come those chances will
come that's right and vashilograph isn't
the type of player who kind of willingly
aims towards shutting things down if he
gets the chance to draw of course later
on then uh he'll take it of course but
uh yeah right now Caro Khan defense
alireza farouza going back to something
we discussed earlier in these really
crunch situations go back to what you
know best go back to what you love and
he's playing his childhood favorite the
caricon defense let's Ivanka when we
need her but meanwhile this last move
has forced black to think alorita
farooja usually trades off a set of
Pawns in the center here but uh of
course in a must-win situation you want
to surprise your opponent and it's not
easy to do that in any opening with
black
what do you think Simon uh is this the
recipe for success
I think I think it's a good idea I
remember uh Wayne Jones one of our um
one of the strongest players in England
Grandmaster but I remember he he
mentioned that when he plays for a win
against 184 uh he always plays the
caracon don't play the Sicilian he used
to play the dragon because there's many
Force lines which can end in Perpetual
checks into a draw if white wants to
play them but he loved playing the
caracom because you get a position which
is dynamic which is uh quite complex
this move though is is a little bit rare
right bring the queen out in this
position
you know I've seen this recommended
recently on Twitter on X I should say
um and yeah I think it was by natilis a
famous opening theoretician and it's
just a way of getting a very safe uh
position with white not taking too much
risk normally it goes against what we're
taught When We're Young of developing
the queen too early but you are gaining
time against Black's Bishop you are
aiming to kind of get the advantage of
the bishop pair and yeah interesting
that fashion he's the one surprising for
Russia
at this early stage yes Bishop goes back
and um uh yeah you mentioned um that
that I was going to say Twitter as well
can I just say Twitter because we all
know what I'm talking about yeah yeah
he's got a great uh he's got some great
ideas uh um on that account but this
queen coming out it kind of uh is quite
an aggressive uh position and um where's
mvl gonna put his King I expect it will
go King side and in the meantime Ali
rays are just developing his pieces
maybe getting ready to open up the
center at the right time uh by pushing
the pawn in front of the King two
squares so it's uh certainly a very
interesting opening position
these caricon positions it's always a
big question for what when to start
pushing Harry the H1 I will not be
surprised if we see that soon enough on
the board
and we will check back if Maxim indeed
decides to go with H4 but action is
about to begin in the Dana slazovic
matchup it has been a three draws so far
in their game going into the fourth
round uh the final rapid game the score
is level chakra is missing from his
chair Dennis lazovic ready with the
black pieces what are the odds of this
one going into an Armageddon predictions
I'll say attack Rihanna if you get this
game he's got whites nothing to lose I
think actually lazovic would be very
happy with an arm again so I think
Shakira is going to throw everything at
his young opponent yeah shark attack for
David Simon I'm gonna go Shack Attack as
well I mean he was warming up in that
last game he got his first piece
sacrifice in and there you know when
Shaq gets in Gears he's like this
bulldozer of energy so uh uh I'll go
Shaq yeah I'm gonna go Dennis the Menace
I think we are going to uh most likely
have an Armageddon in this one I think
Dennis will hold with the black pieces
he has shown incredible solid technique
not giving away any weaknesses making
sure that chakra doesn't get his kind of
positions but we're still waiting for
shark to arrive and the clock is ticking
down yeah the clocks were ticking there
we will update you once uh mamajara
finally does arrive at the board maybe
doing some last minute preparations
there meanwhile vashi the graph looks
like he's attacking himself Bishop to C4
this looks like he's kind of just let
Jess he's going for Scholars mate Queen
on F3 Bishop on C4 but of course there
are no threats right now and black is
very solid here for Asia creating
winning chances that's the kind of big
question carricone Rock Solid opening no
weaknesses really for black but winning
this game still a long way down the line
I'm expecting Knight to F6 here but
maybe he's looking for something a bit
more fruity in this uh must win on
demand situation
it's quite a dangerous position if you
if you don't know your theory here I
think Valley razor because the white
pieces do look quite scary and um Tanya
mentioned the H porn coming up and well
this move I was like can he get away of
it and I'm like surely not because the
white Bishop on those light squares
can't be blocked anymore it looks so
risky this move but he's got to play for
the win so maybe this is the the risk
you needed to take
yeah look at that black king and Center
look at all the pieces undeveloped but
uh we'll check in to see whether version
is able to punish veruga this one
however starts as a nimzo Indian lazovic
has been playing this pretty much his
whole career his young career uh he's uh
thrived in this opening and shakuria
playing the queen C2 variation uh just
developing the White Queen last move
that means that actually maybe he's
gonna play this safe not known for its
attacking kind of options here but uh
okay white does pin the Black Knight
if he takes this Knight it means that
mamajarov wants to play it safe oof
that's a Pity
um I mean you know he's walking into the
hands of Dennis here by playing it safe
and uh yeah I've got to say guys my
prediction looking good right now yeah
that was upsetting that was you know I
was like come on shag you can do better
than this you can attack we want to see
you attack and uh I mean the game's not
over a course but um I'm used to Shaq
pushing his G Pawn pushing his H Pawn of
these kind of positions and it's going
to be a more more positional game now
yeah very positional game white
temporarily has more space due to the
opponent on D4 uh in the center but what
is behind in development so
um I think those two factors cancel each
other out and right now manager of
sliding his Rook across he's getting
ready for black to go for the Thematic
Pawn break in the center black will push
his Pawn to E5 sooner uh rather than
later and manager of just getting his
pieces ready I'm expecting first uh
lazovic to just kind of perfect this and
get the ideal scenario rookie 8 for
example here as as black and still a
well-known position
Theory should favor the younger player
here and I think that E5 break it's
super thematic in these positions but
you have to calculate the lines of what
happens if white actually responds with
his own decentral Bond moving forward
hitting that Knight and a potential
capture in C7 and the chaos that that
happens after that it might just suit
Shakira's style of play the line that
you're pointing at the Knight perhaps
just moves back to E7 it's a nice Square
you can give up the C7 Pawn oh which
maybe white can capture it and I say it
hesitantly looking at the eval bar it
seems to say it's still possible but
things get messy things get really messy
and maybe this is what Mama jar is
banking on maybe I was a bit harsh on
his opening choice I said it was a safe
option but of course any safe position
can explode at the lightest touch so
yeah this would suddenly get chaotic and
lazovic is pausing so maybe just not
expecting uh managera to go down this
slightly
safer Approach at least reputation-wise
a safer approach Rook to E8 would be a
safe move for black Rook to d8 also very
safe but E5 is the acid test of what
white is trying to do if we see a bunch
of trades on this Square then the game
will fizzle out towards equality but
manager of course will not play it safe
E5 seems a bit too risky for Dennis I
don't know but don't want to be rude to
the young young man but he likes keeping
it safe and that's got him this far he's
got to the final by his really risk-free
and brilliantly mature sort of style so
um I I think he'll go rookie eight or
Rook d8 um I like having little bets on
moves though I mean uh would you reckon
anyone anyone gonna go for E5 we've got
an evil I'll take you up on that Simon
yeah
for a beer I reckon yeah only take
quickly only a bit cider for a nice nice
glass of sparkly champagne okay that's
fine I'll take uh whatever I can he's
not gonna go he's thinking about it
because he's spending a lot of time and
it must be the mood to play
um and it's this whole stylistic thing
right it's shark is black oh E5 on the
board instantly you would have played it
two minutes ago you know if Shaq was
black we moved it definitely I don't
even think Shaq will take the pawn I
mean Shaq loves giving up material
um and he loves messy positions but he's
not known to be a pawn Grabber is he as
much as some of the other players so I
don't think he'll want to take that pawn
anyway
um and the thing with top players is
they all have their styles of course but
when the position Demands a certain type
of move even if it's counterintuitive to
them they at least calculate it and uh
if Dennis doesn't see anything wrong
with E5 he might play it the more he
thinks the more I think you might win
the bet Simon that's that's the problem
right now and that's the thing right
David how much time is it going to take
to make this decision as well he's
definitely calculating all these lines
but because it's sort of not an
intuitive approach for a player like
Dennis it means he burns the clock a
little more yeah I think he'll spend
maximum another one to two minutes and
then he'll just play a safe move or
he'll go for it
um I don't think you can really afford
to invest more than uh what he's doing
right now because there's still so much
life in the position it might kind of
really burst into action of course and
you want to leave yourself with enough
time to calculate through that chaos
through the wild Foresters
not too good it's a good night tonight
oh I'll be taking a beer tonight
definitely so uh yep if you're in Oslo
you know where to find Simon tonight he
wins this what was it a glass of I'll
take anything a beer is good so uh I
mean it can't be a bad mood this one it
just seems like Dennis doesn't want to
take too many risks and he's uh getting
ready to open up the central board and a
sensible move yeah very sensible he's
just keeping manager of guessing here
and this can never hurt Black's position
having The Rook opposite the white king
if the Center opens up as we're
expecting it to in the next few moves
then this move will seem like genius
just kind of yeah just setting up this
incoming attack from black so mama jarov
I was expecting him to reply immediately
he chose this opening in rookie 8 as far
as I know it's still a kind of
theoretical move
if I remember correctly white should be
retreating there we go the queen one
square Queen C3
are still well known and the kind of
typical idea here for white is to try
and land the Knight on E5 before black
breaks out
Dennis cannot delay this decision too
much longer and there we go it's got a
player he's got to play E5 here and um
if the position opens up let's remember
that White's King is in central board
and Black's King is castled
um so it's a little bit risky I mean
white therefore keeps keeps the position
close pushes on with a pawn and uh the
night that that looks really odd but
you've got to put the Knight on the
right route Willy grab the pawn now I
mean it looks so scary I I would want to
get castled here rather than grabbing
that pawn
um
uh would you grab it big moment I would
consider grabbing it if I didn't know
any Theory here I would spend maybe two
or three minutes contemplating if I
can't see any punishment for grabbing a
pawn I would play it but the problem is
if you're unprepared your knight is
going to get hit suddenly things are
opening up towards the white king the
Knight can block the Queen's attack on
the B2 Pawn but suddenly uh maybe Pawn
to E3 throwing a spanner in the works
there Black's Knight comes out hitting
the queen as well gaining a lot of time
a lot of Tempe and
I don't know like you said stylistically
not his cup of tea and E3 uh played by
Mama jar after a bit of thought so
taking the safe option but very well
founded positionally Bishop to G4 from
lasovic it's like rules of reverse
suddenly black is the one attacking
white is the one reacting uh but now
Bishop to E2 surely going to be played
by uh my major of blocking this pin
along the diagonal and the game will
take a quieter turn I'll expect at some
point black to try and break out and aim
for in kind of symmetrical Pawn
structure draw whoa what do we have a
draw no what no they're playing Bishop
E2 but the clocks are stopped I think we
do have a result whoa there should be
two and it ends in a draw we get an
Armageddon
wow that was unexpected really
unexpected and that's the theme of the
day just premature draw offers I think
it's the player's Nerfs
wow and just the chess God Kaiser will
it punish manager of taking a quick draw
with white oh my God
which means that Bishop was played and
it is Shakira who actually offered a
draft who accepted it shock saying he
wants to take it into the Armageddon
which means we will have some mind games
between these two for the bidding
Armageddon uh but meanwhile action is
still on in this match these two have
been uh fighting it out till the very
end alirezan needs to win on demand
let's just remind everyone Maxime taking
that big point in game three the lead
and so far everything looks under
control but Maxine does have a long-term
weakness the isolated Queen spawn gives
alireza a Target in the position yeah I
don't think he could have asked for more
from the opening alireza here it's still
balanced enough all the pieces are left
on the board and like you say Tanya
White's Pawn on D4 long term weakness
for sure and okay farouza brings his
Rook to the center nice open file
I think Maxim he's kind of been playing
half with the handbrake on he doesn't
really want to take too much risks of
course there's nothing wrong with
White's position either but how to guide
this game towards safety Simon who would
you pick here I'm I probably pick being
white here
um because generally you know we've got
the isolated Pawn you've got the more
active pieces it's a bit easier to play
but I agree with what you say that
alirez is also uh done the right thing
he's got a dynamic very uh very
complicated double-edged position here
and that's what he needs he doesn't want
a symmetrical Pawn structure he wants a
structure
um which has a lot an older piece on the
board so there's loads loads to play for
here and um yeah yeah this is going to
be interesting to see how it turns up
the time is quite a lot in mvl's favor
um that could be a factor as well but
yeah it looks alright looks right black
and how do you find it playing friends
uh Simon because I know these two have a
lot of respect for each other teammates
at Country uh at the international level
uh I find it tough yeah I mean I I find
it really hard I mean I think as you you
get older you get you know a bit more
used to it but um I mean one thing I was
just doing my friends you know you just
have to forget about when you're playing
the emotions and uh you can always buy
them a drink afterwards and put
everything aside but originally I found
it really hard because that extra Focus
you know yeah and you've got to you know
you want you've got to beat them try to
beat them you can't have quick draws all
the time but you just got to be quite
strong to do that it's always about the
drink afterwards well it's a nice way
it's a nice way to sort of uh you know
if you beat your friend then it's like
okay let's go and chill out if they beat
you then there's uh as we'll say quiet
this is some unfriendly chess here Gary
the Jeep on up the board this is
aggressive I like what mvl's doing
because there's a danger when you only
need a draw in the position that you you
don't take too many risks and um uh you
know he's he's not doing that he's doing
the right thing he's playing
energetically and this seems like a good
move attacking on the king side yeah and
uh the chess Gods might smile upon mvl
only need to draw remember but playing
attacking chess uh let's just go back
one move if it were me a more kind of
passive player here uh a bit move like
Bishop D2 might have stood out just
trying to bring Rooks to the center of
the board trading off heading towards
safety but that would have left uh
farouza feeling uh ambitious feeling
very optimistic G4 however
kind of washes all of those thoughts out
the window G4 is a very aggressive move
for Asia now fighting for survival the
problem is the black Bishop doesn't have
too many safe squares if it drops back
to G6 I think we would see a trade and
mvl here would continue pushing forward
point to G5 momentum now turning in
White's favor because look at this the
F7 weakness which is this kind of uh the
softest point in any position uh is now
attacked twice the bishop and queen
aiming towards it the Knight being
kicked out the way so fruition could not
go for this instead Bishop to E4 played
and after the bishop is captured I'm
expecting him now to take with the Rook
if you take with the Knight again
potential uh disaster lying in your
future on F7 I don't see The Knockout I
don't see a way to immediately crash
through but this looks very risky I'm
expecting Rook takes and note how the
black queen now does cover the key G5
Square so no time for white uh to push
the pawn forward suddenly White's King a
bit weak I said that the chest Gods
would be loving mvl's play but still of
course double edged yeah a very
double-edged position I mean uh White
slight Square Bishop is great in all
these positions so always uh striking
striking across the board here and um
you know
um the root does come in this also
allows the other Rook to to double up
behind it at the same time and we just
we just have a yeah very exciting it's a
very exciting game ah and this is the
maximum that you can hope for right with
black in a must-win situation having
Maxime play uh this kind of Chess go
ahead with that jeep on you've got the
default weakness to Target a potential
White gang that can be weak in the long
run uh the one thing that alireza has to
watch out for is the clock he is under
five minutes Maxim a big advantage on
the clock but again this is going to be
a fight alireza will have his uh chances
I think they're already on the board
yeah and uh mvl here pausing because I
don't think he expected this Rook date
C4 really nice uh nice strong move there
Rook to D1 defending that weakness uh
you mentioned that Tanya and okay what
could be more natural bring the other
black Rook into the game invite all
those pieces to the party
and I like that rookie it yeah yeah
looks free healthy farooza I do worry
about the pasties I've been playing at
just slightly slow today maybe affected
by that defeat in the previous game but
there we go on the board rookie eight
all the black's pieces playing now
yeah we're coming into the game and
white needs to come up with a plan here
as well
um if black can sort of maneuver isn't
his Knight in front of White's isolated
Pawn uh that that I think would start to
really give black a nice Advantage there
so so maybe there's a little bit of
urgency here okay mvl develops his last
piece uh blocking the rook and um what
what side would you take uh here here
guys would you would you rather be white
or black in this position because black
all day every day black will die every
day okay interesting so yeah why do you
do it yeah I think unless there's
something concrete for weight on this F7
Square it doesn't look like you can
break through yet then I would also take
black uh White's position very Dynamic
of course but you do have the long-term
weaknesses and I'm very biased towards
those long-term weaknesses normally I
prefer the bishop pair but here I will
take the safer King as black and uh the
kind of fact you can play and against
this iqp the isolated Queen's born and
Bishop D6 I love this move because
actually you might be willing to part
with the bishop for White's Knight for
example if white just makes a move you
could definitely contemplate taking and
establishing a knight on this beautiful
square that you mentioned Simon and this
Knight is just going to control the
whole board and suddenly the white king
a bit uncomfortable again so I love what
uh farusha is doing it's cost him a lot
of time but
um okay you're taking white we might
have to put another drink on it double
liquids yeah maybe I mean uh that that
is a good idea that you you suggested
them I mean maybe the White Knight can
re-centralize I mean that's the only
thing I'm thinking and try to force the
G Pawn through but it's uh it's heating
up really nicely mvl does have double
the time Advantage here so it's uh it's
uh you know you can use that still in
this position
um but Black's doing all the right
things everything he's doing is
unbalancing it more only one piece has
been exchanged so it's remaining very
complicated and uh lots of play left
yeah to me it feels like the next three
or four moves might be critical either
white find something uh kind of active
to do something to scare his opponent
with start kicking back the black Rooks
for example uh or black just establishes
a nice bind nice control over the
position and uh far Asia from there that
will be the foundations with which he
can try and build some winning chances
yeah
and I was just gonna say let's call out
for the other game Dennis lazovic
against
already already over yeah a quick draw
and it reminds me of something that uh
Robert always says band The draw offer
because the position that that game
ended in it's quite shocking to see you
know you've got to play on and uh a
little disappointing
yeah it's getting quite interesting as
well so so why have the draw but I mean
I can understand why why probably Dennis
wanted to draw because he's kind of
proving over the course of the champions
tour that he's really good in Armageddon
you know he loves playing Armageddon but
Shaq's said in the past that um the
quicker the time limit gets the the less
uh happy he is in general so why I'd
have thought yeah why not play on if
that's the case you know uh you've got
the white pieces you know just just play
some chess
um who do you think's favorite for for
the Armageddon I mean uh I'm gonna go
with Dennis actually now even though
he's the lower rated player he's just
proven he's so good Armageddon so Dennis
would be be my pick
Tanya you go first and I'm just thinking
I think it all comes down to the bid
right uh how low can you go to try and
get the black pieces while you do have
the result odds um
it's a 50 50 and I think whoever gets
black will have a big Advantage as long
as they don't uh go below the nine
minute Mark so I think nine minute over
and black
I think that player wins
okay okay
I'll say
younger player faster on the mouse yeah
experienced in multiple armageddon's as
you mentioned Simon and also I think the
chess guards do have a word uh or they
have a bone to pick with managera for
that decision offering a draw with
weights after just 15 moves
uh but meanwhile this one far from a
draw full of life and your idea now on
the board Simon those Black Knights are
coming in uh just again good kind of
Chess advice blockade your opponents
isolated pawns with knights the black
Knight's gonna land on D5
yeah it looks looks like a good plan
here and um what's white can do I mean
his ideas Knight H5 I mean you can try
this but the the more black is
consolidating the position I think the
better blacks chances are gonna get uh
because you take away the activity of
waste pieces and
um it just becomes easier for black to
play so uh yeah maybe is is not H5 a
move here I mean it's the kind of tactic
that you have to you have to look at for
sure and you've got to try to release
your light Square Bishop towards Black's
King as quickly as you can so yeah I
love it Simon really creative move there
Knight takes night now would be answered
by the very strong Bishop takes porn uh
the king moves and I think you can maybe
take this Rook
um at the very least you could recapture
this Knight and you've won a pawn in the
process uh but yeah Knight H5 I guess
due to the pressure on the F6 Square
black has to go back and defend I'm not
sure how you do that uh something on D5
something on D5 either this night or the
other night on D5 and that's all I know
maybe this night on D5 and you ask white
what this Knight is doing but at least
visually it looks quite appealing looks
like you're kind of threatening
something towards the black king
I guess here as well there is a hit on
your Bishop but this bishop can always
just slide back attacking the black
queen okay instead he doesn't go for
this I like that one actually uh Simon
Knight H5 he attacks The Rook first and
then he goes back he's offering a draw
silently here Maxim he's dropped his
Bishop back to C2 now he's brought it
back to B3 and uh if the black Rook
enters E4 which it will not then he'll
be happy to repeat the position instead
it's the Black Knight that lands on the
E4 Square hinting maybe at some nasty
threats against the White Queen remember
the white king side really open and I
think this might have just favored
farooja slightly this little kind of
transposition of moves
down on the clock though and yeah that
17th piece might just be a decisive
Factor unless he can create something in
the next few turns
yeah yeah I mean it looks uh it still
looks like uh Ali Razor's doing all the
right things there and um
um this this move kind of seemed seemed
like a good idea who's playing for a win
right now H4 he's he he needs only a
draw Maxim he's up a point in the match
he is making some very gutsy position uh
decisions on the board yeah like you say
Tanya he's playing as if it's the last
game of his life as if he needs to win
at all costs taking massive strategic
and uh Dynamic risks here the white king
is never going to feel entirely safe
still of course a challenge to break
through but I like that decision trade
off that white knight land the other
black knight in the center to really
strong uh steeds in the middle of the
board there and there we go kind of
strong and simple chest from farrugia
two minutes though against almost five
it's gonna be a race against the clock
if he wants to stay in this match
up takes Bishop surely gonna happen now
and black will play Knight to D5
ambitious play by Maxim vashire maybe we
should call him maximum I try but this
one with this trade on F4 you recapture
now as you're pointing out the Knight
jumps to D5
white really doesn't want to give up the
light squared Bishop because it's such a
big piece on the board targeting that
then the F7 Pawn I just fear for this
King side play that Maxim has gone for
with G4 H4 it feels like yes you're
being ambitious but it could backfire
really bad for white
yeah certainly the port the pawns I mean
you weaken your own King by pushing your
pawns forwards and uh white white needs
to be uh White needs to be very careful
here uh there's those Rooks the black
Rooks are positioned perfectly and at
the moment his his Bishops they're just
not finding any active roles so I I
would definitely take black now I mean I
was taking white earlier on but just
with the centralization uh blacks black
scenes have the more comfortable
position but it is okay for white uh if
you can get the Queens off make some
exchanges the Bishops might well take
over so it's not it's not a bad bad
position for for white as yeah yeah and
really clever move that defensive move
from Russia to graph I love it Rook C2
uh first I was thinking okay you've got
two Bishops preserve the bishop pair
drop your Bishop back but suddenly the
Black Knight would land with uh
devastating effect on D2 uh just
invading White's position suddenly the
black Rooks as you mentioned there Simon
coming into the game this would have
been uh just uh horrible for white here
instead he defends the square root C2
and he's giving up the correct Bishop if
black takes this one then suddenly white
has counter chances against the black
king white light squared Bishop is the
superior piece the one thing not to do
was take the other uh Knight with uh
your light squared Bishop because
suddenly black has control over all the
light squares for eternity and also
weaknesses on both sides of the board to
watch out for so Rook C2 I think a
really nice kind of controlling move at
the right time he might drop this bishop
back but he's just asking black your
Knights are pretty how do you improve uh
not easy to find a natural uh idea here
for furge and under one minute now
getting dramatic on the clock Last
Chance Saloon he's got to move faster
he's got to up the pace and you saw that
he
had look at the clock and realizes
exactly what you're saying that he is
trying to create his chances it is an
imbalanced position a bishop bear versus
a nightmare in the center and it looks
like he's managed to get that Dynamic
going but what's next how does he keep
the position in an imbalance enough to
get uh those moments where he can strike
and he doesn't trade off keeps as many
pieces on the board as possible jumps in
with a knight and even though the eval
bar doesn't approve this decision I
think from a practical standpoint given
the math situation it is the right way
to go for black it makes a lot of sense
but it is just a one move threat if
white slides across actually this
improves the white position suddenly
blacks Rooks look a bit vulnerable
White's going to double up Stack Up on
the e-file and yeah shaking his head
there yeah he's not so happy with that
move as well and why he's moved back and
I don't think it's not a good sign it's
not a good sign I don't think mvl will
go back because he's he's improved his
position as you say why not double up on
the on the open file now and increase
some pressure there uh it's just time I
mean you can't play ottoman chess when
you're under a minute no matter who you
are no matter if you are uh and he
raiser one of the best bullet players in
the world
um so yeah I mean maybe Dublin Brooks is
the way to go don't see a problem with
that so
MVR will you go backwards we've seen
this happen throughout the night right
Alias are really low on the clock and
Maxine putting pressure not only with a
really imbalanced Dynamic aggressive
position where anything can happen
blunders can happen any moment but also
having those extra couple of moments in
critical decision time and now Knight D5
played he's up by three minutes on the
clock and I think the clock will really
matter in this one yeah that's how he
decided things Maxim he really upped the
intensity in the previous game when
ferger is down on the clock he does
eventually play the D Rook to E1 so much
tension between the Rooks now it's kind
of like a stare off and farooja is the
first one to Blink dropping back with
his Knight now all the Rooks can leave
the board firstly who does that favor
secondly white can actually plug the
e-file Bishop to E5 looks very tempting
as well
suddenly far Asia with not much time on
his clock he will not be able to react
to any surprise that fishing Expedition
he went on with Knight to B4 is
backfired and suddenly white is
reestablishing some control taking
Brooks off the board taking Brooks off
the board and even the bishop can jump
to G5 really pinning that Knight on F6
and targeting a lot on the diagonal
Bishop G5 is an attractive move here but
the Rook on E1 hangs right now I almost
watched walked into that yeah so this
this first seems like a good move and
one of the things I learned when you
when you're playing against Knights when
you had the Bishops is you can use your
pawns to restrict those to restrict
those squares so I'm kind of thinking
the pawns on the king side now are quite
useful because they can uh uh take away
a lot of squares of the Black Knights uh
here so uh I like mvl's position
actually he's played this really well
the Bishops have got open lines but
anything still possible the time though
also massively in mvl's favor yeah and
you'll move your idea on the board now
Tanya nice move David what happens if
black gets greedy and picks up the D4
his King side is wrecked it's ruined the
question is does white jump in play
Queen takes F6 Black's Queen is going to
take on G4 with a check there uh White
has some pawns uh disappearing orders
white just slow play it Retreat the
white Rook you have great compensation
for just the one Pawn sacrifice
I mean that's a crazy line right Queen
F6 Queen G4 and the King goes to H2 I
don't see another check for black there
and you've got this threat against the
F7 Pawn as well as the Rook sliding on
to G5 with a check coming in yeah
actually the more I look at it I think
uh you're just completely correct here
Tanya uh you're breaking through on
either F7 or with Rook G5 how does black
stop this all uh I don't see it any goes
in fashion agrov going in for the kill
farusha's got to defend this with just
13 seconds on his clock I mean I was
thinking Queen G7 but I it I mean you
can win the piece here at least if you
go Queen G7 uh um with Rook G5 uh and
that that should be enough to win the
game actually or maybe not so uh this
does I thought win a piece after Queen
takes Queen and H5 but and then the king
moves forward I think that's the point
five as well yeah rookie five and black
suddenly better so uh of the queen G7
where's the win he has played it so it
looks like there should be a win here
but oh just Queen D6 nice just keeping
the pressure no need to rush and I like
the fact he used the F1 Square there
might have been some other checks but a
draw was not enough for a for Asia so
now the white king is super safe and the
pressure on the e-file might just be
decisive Queen f8 What a Sad move look
at those black pieces huddled together
on the back Rank and now where is the
finishing touch at the very least you
could probably just uh repeat go back to
F6 but H5 he's moving in for the kill
here bashilograph he's going for some
nasty checks and it's going to be a
miracle if black can survive this yeah
he's put his King in the corner but uh
it's really really looking bad he can
hardly move any of his pieces
um at this moment in time so
yeah you can give another check with the
White Queen black will be forced to
block
10 seconds yeah it's been uh I think
just impractical clock handling from
farrugia yeah
and you could do that right give a check
Force black to block the check with the
queen and then come back to the square
that you're on and almost force a
repetition because the Knight on E7 is
pinned very professional yeah very nice
way of doing it I mean maybe black can
try F6 but yeah you're right I mean that
that could be a good way doing it you
could play H6 here as well
but he's gone for the check and he's
just grabbing the pawn here and you
can't yeah you can't take the queen
because you'll lose your knight you
can't take the route because you lose
your rook and he's he's gone for it he's
gone for it the ball does react there's
no way to force a draw yet and suddenly
Black's Queen is centralized Queen and
Knight tend to be a good Duo against
Queen and Bishop
is America is a miracle gonna happen do
Miracles exist farooja give us a check
with his Queen
suddenly the clock's balancing out you
can give another check I think vashid
Grove maybe slightly rushed he didn't
need to force the issue he had full
control and okay the checks will not uh
kind of run out just yet but a draw not
sufficient for farooza is he gonna take
this white Bishop
was he going to go back and give a check
okay it's going to be a pure Queen end
game but black maybe gonna be a pawn up
temporarily only all three results
possible yeah now both players playing
on second so all three results
definitely possible but for others only
one counts he needs to find a way to win
this one he does
he the material is level right now so he
gives the check picks up the night you
can pick up the B2 Pawn but the 87 Pawn
is hanging so actually that check by
Maxine was very smart making sure that
the black skin isn't connected to the 87
Pawn anymore yeah very very smart it was
upon sacrifice what he did but now he's
banking on the fact that the black king
has no shelter oh it's a narrow path
though because if the black king does
ever evade the checks Black's extra
material should count yeah I mean he
should definitely win on The Queen side
here and uh I don't I mean these
positions are so hard to work out if you
have a Perpetual check or not
um and he's grabbed the pawn back here
uh banking on this idea but this this is
just complicated this could go either
way with 10 seconds under 10 seconds
each on the clock it's not ah it's not
straightforward at all also Imagine
mvl's mind vashilcraft inside his mind
he's like okay I had it I was one move
away I was in control and suddenly the
black pawn is running he's gonna have no
uh kind of certainty here that he's
still holding he's going to give some
checks but he's got to hope the checks
don't dry way up yeah and compare the F
Pawn with black C Pawn black pawn is
running much faster and now the king
jumps in to actually assist it it
doesn't matter what the eval Bar says
for maxim it's not going to be easy to
hold this he's only relying on checks
right now pushing that pawn can black
also uh start going ahead with the c
Pawn the race is incoming it is we can
see Four Queens on the board
but I this this has got so much better
for alireza and he's got uh just the
kind of position he would have dreamed
of like 10 well 20 moves ago now and is
black skin going to find safety on that
A1 square and black is winning black is
just winning we're gonna see Four Queens
we're gonna see Four Queens but normally
in these positions with Four Queens it's
the person who moves first and that is
going to be alireza I think what's going
to be decisive also Simon says that
Black's King is really close to that A2
Pawn so if all the Queens are off the
board black will actually win the King
Pawn ending that uh comes ahead yeah
Four Queens officially on the board but
checkmate's coming surely that white
king is not going to be able to survive
this this kind of barrage of checks but
only two seconds left to find the check
mate yeah the King has to step into the
middle and um I mean it looks I mean how
are you supposed to calculate this
position it's absolutely impossible to
work it out it was second and one could
never trade Queens what was that your
mouth slipper it must have been a bad
slip I think
I think Dupont wow wow that is
incredible you just got to keep checking
I mean you know you can't give your
opponent the initiative Here and Now
white must at least have a draw here
because he's just got too many blunder
he had to come back with the king so
blunder now white can Checkmate very
actually simply by bringing his Queen
across to B4 using the two white coins
together it's all about those checks
like you say Simon pawn count is
irrelevant and uh now I found that way
doing it and that was a that was an
amazing game another very exciting
encounter there what effects that was by
alireza Fairuza and was in his hands but
Maxim vashiella grav the fighter he
takes that one opportunity that he got
but he knows this was close and he does
react uh that was a reaction of relief
right there Maxine Bashir lagrav taking
the win and
foreignment so close
so close he did everything right he
survived the worst he completely turned
it around and one or two accurate moves
away from Victory ah the clock came back
to haunt him
and uh it was here actually really
unique once in a lifetime type of
position with Four Queens on the board
and uh it was all about checks black
would actually be winning if he had
played the move Queen to beat two check
he actually used the square for his King
and that backfired Queen to B2 check
it's not easy to foresee this you have
to calculate a lot in advance but uh
here with some very accurate moves I
think Queen to E6 uh you would
eventually be winning the black the
white king would eventually be forced
onto the edge of the board and the two
black coins together would team up and
unite instead we saw a full 360. maybe a
mouse lip meaning to take this Pawn
instead he played King B2 uh for Russia
and then we saw the checkmating pattern
the two white queens were the ones to
team up in the end and this King was
caught in no man's land on C4 dynamite
and game over rational graph progresses
a very exciting game there I mean that
that was going back because before as an
mvl kind of let it slip
um farooza came back there and in the
end he just got a little bit greedy you
know Tempo is so important in chess and
uh you gotta you've got to keep the
checks up when you got them and handle
your clock a bit better I guess what an
incredible fight that was why Olivers
are playing with the black pieces uh
finding that opportunity to create his
chances when Maxine got ambitious with
the play uh and you've got to give
full marks to alireza for being able to
do that and in the end uh just missing
it yeah if you had a bit more time there
another 30 seconds then I'm sure he
would have found that that tricky win
that David pointed out so so difficult
but I think King A2 was actually a must
slip when he did move that King to B2 I
think he did mean to pick up that A2
Pawn because we saw him reacting there
on the screen and could have been very
different yeah King takes A2 if he
hadn't now slipped he would have kept
the game going I think white would have
been able to trade off one set of Queens
which was a Pity I enjoyed that being
four on the board but um the game would
have gone on a long time and I think for
Asia would still have been a favorite so
again a slight bit of panic uh the mouse
kind of uh the mouse skills slightly
lacking there in the end just close but
not close enough but these are the kind
of fights that we live for right so much
entertainment and so much action on the
board and uh the this is where we stand
on our score line the action does
continue because we got one Armageddon
coming up while uh Magnus Carlson and
Jana from the she wrapped their matches
in just three games dominated their
matchups Maxime washer that was a roller
coaster of a match and we do have Maxime
joining us in the studio for an
interview Maxim what a crazy match
congratulations
thank you another this last game I mean
I I cannot believe myself
what happened take us through because
Four Queens on the board until the very
last moment Anything Could Happen
no I mean at first it looks like nothing
could happen I was doing very well I
played some good moves
and some of them I blended this Quincy
one check
which was not that difficult to see
was a bit tougher to defend some you
know a position where I was actually
much better or even winning and where I
just needed to draw
um and at the end I was just ready to
resign because there were a few wins for
Louisa but I think he must sleep with
King B2
Oak index it I don't know that like
uh maybe some Panic there but you know
uh just that everything was winning with
this Four Queens for him of course and
I was already like
thinking I will could I lose this but
turns out I didn't
and uh Maxima it seemed to be a high
quality match from move one both of you
throwing everything at each other
um some crazy games there but until game
three uh everything in the balance what
do you think was the turning point of
the whole day
I mean definitely game three was a huge
turning point because I was under some
pressure because
um I mean I always had done his homework
and this either flying I know it's okay
for black but there are a few accurate
moves to do and uh
and then after this bishop takes B5 I
um wanted to very deep thoughts and play
and turns out then I checked and more or
less everything uh I was considering was
okay but what I did turned out not only
to be okay but uh to give the impression
I think told us that he had something
very decisive and they spent a lot of
time couldn't find it and then I think
got frustrated and and then the end
tables were turned around and then this
game four hours keeping control
all right 95 of the game and there was
this moment this blender which uh I'm
just very lucky not to
not to go into game four
and Maxine we do have a question from
our chat uh from the future chat from
crumble dabs and asking how would you
calculate an endgame a crazy end game
like that at the end
well I mean there was no time to
calculate but uh you know generally just
doing the right check and I thought some
point
um like he could do check with the other
queens and exchange one queens and
exchange the other and you know in
general just exchange boss Queens uh and
then taking my opponent promoting so
boss everything was an option so you
know I
um I think Ali went crazy because you
really should have converted this one
and another question from the chat uh
Maxime and that is um does having the
French football team shirt does does
that improve your ELO improve your play
yes well in first main nationality in a
way but
uh
I don't think
uh anything it was just you know this
was a French match so I thought
yeah I might as well bring the French
shirts
and really coming back to these Four
Queens and games so I got
two of those in recent years both of
which I saved actually so it's the third
time but this one I was losing in the
other two it was
against England in 2019 I think and
against Pearl Max Zulu I want to clean
this Knight of lines that we've seen
today
um last year
Maxine that was a fantastic match to
watch really entertaining uh chess by
both you and Alex and while in this one
experience prevailed we've got a big
Armageddon coming up between uh Dennis
Las Vegas and chakra mamidarov and
before you go I'd love to get your
thoughts on how you expect that one to
play out
but I don't even know how much time
they get so you know
it might depend on that might depend on
how much time my black gets
versus game uh but it seemed to be very
even much
so you know I think anything can happen
there
anything can happen and we will find out
the bids very soon Maxim thank you so
much for joining us and for all your
insights all the best for tomorrow
thank you Tanya thank you
Maxime after a roller coaster match
against alireza faruja takes the win now
Four Queens on the board we don't get to
see that often and now it is uh going to
be time for the bids to come in really
soon and we will find out who plays with
black who gets the result odds on the
other side of this very short break
[Music]
is an online sensation the teenager
known as denlaz has been taking down
experienced Grandmasters for many years
already
a specialist in Blitz chess and Rapid
chess Dennis lazovic has now qualified
for division one of the Champions chess
tour and he did it in style with his
uncompromising tenacious and resilient
style of play Dennis lazovic is truly
unique for such a young player he's able
to positionally outplay his opponents
he's able to outmaneuver them and with
his solid openings he has a perfect base
to emphasize his rapid skills
when given a tactical opportunity
however Dennis lazovic does pounce check
out this position from division two of
the aim chess rapid which lazovic went
on to win here Dennis lazovic who's
White against Parham mag Zulu White had
a material advantage being up a rook for
Black's Bishop but the finishing touches
to this game are still needed
lasovic here of course found the most
brutal way to finish the game the most
decisive move and it was a sacrifice
Rook to h8 giving up the Rook on an
empty square a check of course this Rook
simply has to be captured and this
allowed the White Queen to zoom in to f8
a square no longer protected by the
black king again black has only one
legal reply King to H7 and this allowed
the finishing touch the other Rook
slides over to the vacated H1 Square
that's a check the black king is simply
trapped and here Parham maxulu resigned
rather than giving up his Queen on H6
this would have led to Checkmate anyway
and Max Zulu won a masterpiece going to
h8 checkmate
and we will have the bids coming in
really soon as Maxine said it all comes
down to who gets the black pieces and
what the bids are uh how low can you go
is the big question danislavik again
chakra mama diaro and here they are so
not very low seems to be the answer and
it is Dennis lazovic who wins the bid
with a 10 minutes and chakra Mama dear
of 11 minutes to 20 seconds does that
imply that he he kind of did want the
white pieces uh David yeah
um it feels like it's kind of in the
middle of their mama Joe if he was in
two minds very happy with white of
course otherwise you would bid lower but
yeah I think yeah it's really hard to
call who's going to be the favorite now
Dennis lazovic that's a pretty high bit
himself 10 minutes and uh now with black
I think he's gonna be glad
the way things worked out and let's
remind the newer chess fans all the
rules of the Armageddon that these
players will be playing against Dennis
lazowick wins the bid with the lower bid
gets to choose the color chooses black
with which he gets the result odd so he
stops with 10 minutes his bedtime but
the draw means that black wins the match
for chakri or mamidaro he starts with
the base time which is 15 minutes but
has to win on demand and because of that
he decides to switch it up in the nimsa
Indian instead of going for the very
solid full Queen C2 he goes for the
signage setup of the nimso Indian which
we know is an aggressive one
yeah and a very interesting opening here
I mean Chuck was offering a pawn there
in the middle of the board and uh
um black uh declining that offer and
looks like I didn't know the fury there
David were you were you aware of that no
sacrifice typical Shack kind of idea
typical Shack kind of idea and uh yeah
as far as I know it is Theory but very
rare type of theory uh just crazy stuff
early days in this encounter it's
definitely Shakura trying to play
aggressive note how quickly he's been
playing only spent 10 seconds on the
board and we're already at move 10
um but yeah it's definitely a case of
trying to switch things up trying to be
more direct and Dennis lazovic takes the
bait here he does grab a pawn instantly
by castles this is terrifying even if
you have two hours on your clock facing
one of the world's greatest attacking
players and he's coming at you he's
giving away gameting pawns and saying
I'm going to go for that black king in
the next few moves yeah it looks like he
might know his theory though I mean this
is the kind of position because it's so
sharp and you would have to put a lot of
back into and uh obviously Shaq now in
the position as well after moving so
quickly there the bishop just retreating
and you can see White's compensation
he's got open lines for his Bishops open
lines for his rook and his King is
castled as well so it's uh it looks like
clear compensation here
create compensation for the sacrifice
material it is a two-point deficit right
now for white and Dennis latvik quite
quickly reacting by bringing his night
out and the Dilemma is where to Castle
the black king that's been a theme of
the day where to put your king for it to
feel safe and Quint E1 a nice side step
getting out of a pin White's night now
is free and if the black king does pluck
up the courage to Castle kingside I
think there might be tactics against it
the Greek gift I'm just thinking about
that what you have in mind David if
black does go shark Castle is it time
and is it that moment where we might see
a sacrifice on 87 and the White Knight
jumping forward and the White Queen
coming to the H4 square and Checkmate to
follow I think you've called it Tanya
exactly all of that is gonna happen and
this is a Greek gift luring out uh kind
of tricking the black king out of its uh
safety there and if the black king drops
back simply Checkmate is coming on H7
you can only delay this now and if the
king comes forward then of course it
will get checkmated anyway I guess Queen
to E4 may be the quickest path and a
block would be met by on passant and the
King will die a painful death so instead
Dennis lazovic cannot allow this of
course and he does not allow this
instead removing one of those key
attackers in that variation removing the
Knight and getting ready to Castle
queenside Maybe
jakura just not caring at all giving two
pawns up it's just like the previous
game two Bishops against two knights and
uh okay now it's a one-point deficit but
the black king still has questions to
answer Dennis lasvik he's using Knights
as blockaders hoping that they will
Shore up the defense and Simon do I have
to ask you who you favor here yeah I
mean I I always take the attacker but I
I do like what Dennis has done he's got
his Knights blockading the pawn uh
blockade in the middle of the board and
he's got some nice squares them he's got
C5 Square as well
um so it's it's certainly not uh the end
of the world uh for him by any means and
he's now got his King safe how does
white generate more attacks where he
brings his Rook maybe his Rook can swing
round and uh you know obviously a shack
position we talk about Shaq positions
he's one of the most creative attackers
um you're ever gonna see and uh that
time Advantage has got nearly twice the
time so yeah I take white basically uh
yeah a long long way to say that but 100
yeah you love going for the king and as
you mentioned it is all about the
initiative that Shakura mamidaro has for
that pawn with the bishop pair the rook
and the queen already in the left a
potential uh Bishop retreat with the
Rook coming to the eighth Line This most
likely surprises me David and I see an
expression that you're surprised as well
yeah I just don't see the point of uh
White's light squared Bishop being on F5
it's not as if you ever ever want to
trade off uh either of your Bishops for
the Black Knights you need to keep the
Bishops as a pair in order to attack but
yeah maybe Shakura is happy to slow play
it he believes in his uh long-term
compensation here it's very Alpha
zeroesque uh talking of AI Alpha zero
always happy to give up pawns for the
two Bishops for long term uh kind of
control this white Pawn on E5 means that
there will always be attacking chances
and for Dennis the question is what next
how does black improve his pieces
the one thing that you'd want to be
careful about playing with black in this
position is the Jeep onto G6 yeah yeah
and it might still be fine but you
weaken so many docs quests in that
situation which again long term becomes
a huge problem G6
is a move and I see the valve bar
doesn't react so it seems it's fine but
from a human perspective you never want
to play it imagine one's White's Bishop
lands on H4 with that Rook H3 idea that
you set Bishop H4 Bishop F6 and you're
talking big trouble for black hair yeah
I totally agree maybe this is why Shaq
put the bishop on that square maybe he's
just trying to attempt uh his younger
opponent into making some moves that
will weaken his position but saying that
I think if you know maybe after
something like Rook H3 or something
along those lines G6 is is a move you
would imagine you can't play it like
Bishop H4 so uh Shaq clearly thinking
about Rook H3 that looks like the route
one tactic and when you're calculating
these positions you always calculate
Route One straight away yeah maybe he
was scared of the move Knight to G5 here
just uh kind of counter-attacking and
defending because he's played one of
your favorite moves Simon but a bit kind
of strange in this exact situation
because looks like the white Bishop
wanted to use that square and uh King
side attack met by a counter on the
other flank B5 from Dennis lazovic and
uh he's trying to distract White's
attention uh from the black king really
fascinating stuff here blow met by
counter blow and whose pieces will
prevail Bishops or Knights I'm a bit
surprised that he's opening things up
Dennis uh considering he has Knights
versus Bishops kind of normally that
would favor the Bishops but make sense
he's playing on the side that he's
stronger right now
yeah yeah he's I mean he's got to get
counter play he's got uh an extra Pawn
over on that side of the board so uh
he's uh he's trying to open it up on
that area of the board uh but I am
surprised by H4 I mean I normally like
H4 but you can never swing your Rook
over to that open line now and that's
that's a real pain
um so what does white do now to increase
any pressure against Black's King and it
looks like the White Queen is maybe on
the wrong side of the board if you if
you could move the queen and put it over
on G4 then it'll be uh game on again you
know get the queen nearer to the black
king but can't see anything obvious for
for Shaq here yeah and this uh this is
Armageddon and the clock is half the
battle what do you think of the time
usage of both players so far as plays a
mysterious uh move there
I think it's okay I mean uh that Dennis
I mean you don't get any added time uh
Dennis has proven time and time again
that he he's really quick he can move at
that uh at the speed of light so uh he's
got enough time and he's dealing with
all the threats incredibly well I mean
he's the kind of play he just doesn't
get shaken at all you know it doesn't
feel the pressure he keeps his calm uh
incredibly well
but I think even for shock he's done a
good job keeping that edge on the clock
as well let's not forget that it is a
must win with the white pieces so he's
created his initiative that mysterious
looking move that you pointed out and at
some point it could Target the F7 Pawn
no one can imagine The Bishop's out of
the way and then suddenly you've got
these threats I also really like that
shock has actually paused and not made
the immediate recapture on C4 he's
perhaps thinking about that light Squad
Bishop that we're talking about moving
back to B1 or
maybe trading on E6 I was thinking that
maybe it was paid but then I realized
David you made the move Bishop B1 uh the
bar reacts it's probably not a great
idea because one of the knights can also
jump on to D3 to release some of the
pressure uh but shock clearly not
thinking about recapturing and restoring
material balance but looking at ways to
create attack against black skin here
yeah there are various ways I like yours
as well Tanya if this Pawn didn't exist
there might be ideas of setting up a
battery along this diagonal forcing
weaknesses uh kind of inducing uh a kind
of a hook on the king side with which to
attack but I think eventually he'll come
to the conclusion that your uh kind of
counter idea then Knight to D3 is a bit
of a threat so he did get rid of this
pawn and Dennis instantly reacting uh
taking advantage of the white Queen's
absence from the C3 Square Suddenly by
attacking the undefended e-pawn so can
Shakura whip up some kind of threats out
of nowhere before black gets greedy and
takes this keep on off the board it's
not going to be easy he does have this
limited window of opportunity the
problem is there as well if you go to
defend it with your Bishop for example
then there might be hits on your
remaining pieces Knight to D4 suddenly
uh this Square not covered so you have
to be really careful if you're managerov
yeah definitely it really feels like
sort of the Calm before the storm for
White's position the Rooks lined up on
the f-line dot x-raying that F7 Pawn the
Bishops on the open diagonal black feels
the pieces are a bit loose playing on
the clock as well David again I don't
think it's a moment that shark will try
and defend the E5 Pawn he's looking for
ways to actually create a threat in in
Black's Camp here uh Simon what are the
attacking ideas that come to your mind I
mean the first of all I was wondering if
you could play Bishop takes H7 but I
just and then Rook F7 but that just
doesn't work at all because uh you can
just take the Rook on F7 I mean this is
the kind of thing you've got to look at
there's no good bishop move I mean it's
just nonsense but uh you've got to try
to find the weak points in your
opponent's position and just try to uh
open them up so I'd love to get my queen
over but uh again I don't see how that
helps so he's uh he is opening up I like
it yeah I like it he's got to get his
Rooks going and he's opening up blinds
for his Rooks now and uh I I mean you
know this is the position kind of
position that Shaq just loves playing
you know he loves attacking he loves
having the initiative so he's got what
we said before the match he wanted to
get him what he needs to get you must uh
be feeling proud right now Tanya your
idea what's on the board
and David you called out you want to get
rid of that C4 Pawn before you plant
your bishop and we want to control that
D3 square and I also want to point out
this position is getting me pretty
excited that if black was to take that
Central E5 Pawn I think the bishop on F2
jumps onto G3 with a Tempo hitting that
rook and suddenly those Rooks lined up
on the F line yeah yeah suddenly the
dust is cleared and uh White is crashing
through on F7 this scared Dennis lazovic
so much that he played a passive looking
move after Bishop back to B1 he played
Rook f8 kind of over protecting the F7
Square I think very very wise and now my
Majora does take a time out to protect
his Pawn he wants to somehow get this
bishop out the way but only at the right
moment black is a bit stuck so white
will have a few moves to build up I
think Quincy 3 this last move by a
manager of really clever in terms of the
Armageddon uh format here he's just not
giving black any intuitive any obvious
moves he's keeping the tension and
saying okay your clock is ticking I'm
three and a half minutes up uh good luck
mate try and find a move not easy for
Dennis lazovic those Black Knights kind
of hanging uh together one of them
Retreats very logical
can he continue creating threats
yeah I mean he's doing everything he can
at the moment he's got that nice time
advantage of like three and a half
minutes as well uh but so far Dennis has
defended kind of perfectly I don't think
I've ever seen like Dennis blunder you
know he he he really rarely blunders
maybe when he got short time against uh
Ali Razer in the last Edition but in
general he just plays he plays very well
and uh I think in order to win this one
um you're gonna have to try to induce a
blunder off Dennis somehow so what does
white do here I am I mean you can you've
got to try to get your pieces to the
maximum squares this makes a lot of
sense because F7 is is not a Target
anymore so over defend your Pawn maybe
try to again give yourself she needs to
swing to Rook around and uh yeah just
just keep the pressure up that's all he
can do that's all he can do in the Black
Knights now kind of retreating back some
really awkward squares uh the Black
Knight has gone back to d8 to protect a
loose Pawn the pawn on C6 but also
continuing the threats on White's e-pawn
it's really kind of not making a great
impression though the fact that black
has kind of reduced those glorious
nights previously to passive pieces can
white punish
okay white bonus and uh I see our chat
is also torn between Dennis and shark in
this match a lot of support coming in
for both these players uh it truly is a
position where anything can happen each
move from both sides is a high
responsibility move I think for Dennis
to keep control of the position with the
bishop that shark has the attacking
possibility he has to be really careful
and tactically alert and shock right now
just keeps the pressure on he keeps
everything guard it defends that E5 Pawn
which was threatened by Dennis with that
last move and also let's point out that
that Bishop from B1 can actually slide
over to another diagonal well at a good
moment Bishop A2 ideas are always in the
air where you hit the rook and start
targeting the F7 Pawn from the other
side of the board definitely in the area
actually would have been extremely
strong a bit earlier but um okay Dennis
leswick he's given up this Pawn on C6
now no more material advantage for black
that was the one thing fuse that was
worth suffering for and now he's kicking
away this black Rook which lands on D2
he's hoping for counter play maybe even
a sacrifice of The Rook for this key
Bishop but uh it does feel like it's
turning it in White's favor now if you
can somehow evict this Rook Black's only
active piece then white has a huge
Advantage I'm expecting a move like
Queen back to E4 Queen to C3 something
just to keep control and uh okay he
trades off a set of Rooks my first time
I'm surprised in a while by my Majora's
move in Armageddon you want to keep
pieces on the board especially when
you're so active especially when you're
playing with white in a must-win
situation he does trade off the Rooks
black can't pick up the A3 Pawn the
queen on E7 needs to keep the D7 Knight
defended and now we do see a block of
the diagonal with the move G6 also
creating a loft for the black king
yeah I wonder if white wants to even
exchange Queens in this position just
just move the queen over and try to get
them off and uh play that ending I mean
I I wouldn't really want to do that he
does say okay so he's relying on those
two Bishops and a Rooks I mean they're
they're two Bishops and The Rook works
so well together uh later on but Dennis
is is a solid solid player and uh he
knows how to uh how to you know tuck up
in a ball and uh stop his opponents
getting at him so this is this is tough
I think this is now very tough to win
this actually yeah it feels like things
are really in the balance uh mama jarov
had this dream attacking position but
he's gone against his instincts and
remember lazovic is really good in the
end game also the time difference which
started at five minutes at the beginning
of this game is now down to under two
minutes uh Dennis eating away at that
and position still relatively solid uh
White's Bishop cannot go and grab the
pawn on A7 yet without loosening up your
position slightly okay he's just
positioning here so so tense right now
Bishops versus Knights what do you favor
here
what I normally like the Bishops as well
but the knights are quite well situated
in the middle and they block everything
up so they're not too bad I mean I still
take the Bishops uh White's light Square
Bishop is is so strong just striking
across the board and
um with this last move Dennis is trying
to get his Knights working even better
um but you can now even think about
maybe taking that Knight I wouldn't
necessarily want to do that but
so so close here and let's keep an eye
on the clock as well because it's 5
minutes 20 uh for Mama jarov and three
minutes 40 for Dennis you don't get any
time added on that's uh the key thing
with Armageddon
I don't think uh shock is going to let
go of his Bishops very early on that
trade is not going to happen he needs to
keep as many pieces as much pressure and
tension on the board as the clocks run
low let's remind everyone there is no
increment in the Armageddon so flagging
is uh encouraged it's a big part of the
battle and King to G7 so again just
making a slow move here how can white
keep up building that pressure that
we're talking about here yeah that's the
thing it's not easy I see for example we
have a comment from the chat here saying
it does not look good for black right
now but the thing is I think it kind of
it looked worse a bit earlier on it was
really hard to find moves you're facing
a kind of blistering attack suddenly you
have uh passed to Salvation if the
Queens come off if you can get rid of
one of White's Bishops maybe you'll be
able to hold the draw there if you can
trade to the queens and the Rooks off
you're relatively solid the knights
might hold their own there all sorts of
end games they're potentially savable
for black right now so yeah manager of
as well it's not his type of position
the time difference is down to under one
minute and I don't know about you guys
but I fear for Shakira's mouth skills
against the Young
kind of whipper snapper here Dennis
lessovich if he gets I think it gets to
one minute each then Shaq's going to be
in big trouble because uh Dennis is just
the quicker player so he's got to try
and get something big from the position
before that happens but his Rook is now
maybe swinging across he he has got
equal material Here Comes The Rook
keeping pressure on Bland's kingside and
uh
um I mean if you're gonna pick a side
you'd always pick white here right you
never pick black on the chessboard but
uh Dennis is is so resilient for for
such a young player and can he get
active now with his Rook I mean could be
some counter-attacking chances coming
soon
and my skills are a big part of
Armageddon well right now we see the
queen has retreated and might find its
way over to the king side also for shock
he always has this Harry the H Pawn
going further up H5 trying to create uh
weaknesses on the king side H5 always a
threat that black needs to watch out for
but right now black has a threat of his
own
am I jumping on the night on E6 can't
even move because of the F7 Pawn yeah
maybe the other night wants to come to
D5 centralized but suddenly the
evaluation bar reacts and I think we
need a helping hand from the engine why
is it so excited now about White's
position wow it says there are various
strong moves but the strongest was
Bishop to B3 the black Rook actually
lacking some good squares but I think
the more logical the more human approach
here adopted by Mama jarov attacking
hinting at some threats against the
black king but also opening up as well
after the White Queen to come over and a
blunder because Pawn to H6 is a killer
blow black king now forced onto the back
rank if it had taken that pawn White
Queen would have zoomed into f8 with a
devastating check and now how to finish
the black king is almost trapped it's
caught him in a mating maybe you've got
Rook F7 I mean that that is okay Rook F6
first uh coming in and uh look at the
Bishops now the Bishops are just flying
uh towards Black's King and Black's King
has surrounded the back rank is weak as
well and uh yeah though every thing is
bad for black in this position it's just
that one move right that was the problem
with defending you know you can hold on
for so long but then things crack maybe
Queen F4 the queen coming over now from
White uh attacking some of Black's
Pieces Just just seems to hold
everything together even Bishop G3 and
you know there's so many tempting moves
there Simon Queen A4 I love your idea
because I think if you go back with the
1986 which seems like the way to stop
that F7 threat there's a huge sacrifice
which might work with rookie six and the
queen jumping onto F6 this could be the
end
immediately Shaq is going to be going
through is Queen F6 game over yeah
there's no way you can stop all the
threats there Queen G7 will win the game
now we saw the headshake from lazovic we
saw manager of his eyes darted off to
the side I think he was checking out his
opponent's camera there and he sits back
he sips his drink he's breaking through
Checkmate in one threatened Queen G7
Bishop takes E6 secondary threat as uh
you said Tanya it is game over no way to
uh stem the tide anymore but a really
important secondary threat because Queen
F7 actually runs into Bishop E6 and that
is the winning idea of this exchange
sacrifice and shark knows it thanis
lazovic knows it there's nothing that
you can do to fight the Checkmate or
lose your queen shock your mommy with
that bid
and also going back in time with that
fourth game early draw made it very
clear that he was confident of his
chances with the white pieces and we do
have a result queen of six and Dennis
lazovic resigns a mamidara of Shakira
are after a stunning Armageddon takes
the match and there he is the winner he
made it clear that he was confident of
his chances going into the Armageddon
playing for the win bidding for the
white pieces Dennis lazowick what a
fight he put up
what a fight and in the end it was just
decided by one or two moves manager have
kept the pressure and eventually lazovic
did crack and it was a difficult
position the Clock Was ticking and uh it
was here that mamajorov did clinch the
wind black had to play a move such as
Knight D5 uh just for example keeping
this Knight on E6 because it covers the
key f8 Square watch how this becomes
relevant when the Knight moved away Pawn
to H6 was the killer blow hoping for the
black king to come forward because then
the White Queen swoops in and the King
will not survive much longer the King
was instead forced back to the back Rank
and as we saw the killer sacrifice
giving up the white rook in order to
bring the queen in and this H Pawn which
Advanced a bit earlier has does now play
a key role Queen to G7 Checkmate
threatened and Bishop takes E6 this king
is doomed and lazovic resigned
really nice combination there at the end
to end a game that showed exactly what
he's called the shark attack and this is
our score line at the end of day one
Shakura mamidaro Maxima Magnus Carlson
and Jana pomnishi continued through in
the Winner's bracket
Anish giri and Dennis lazawik will go
down to their last strike and will fight
it out in the losers bracket big matches
big results today
so much action Simon what impressed you
the most
um I will say Magnus but I mean I'm
gonna have to say Magnus again because
he dominated that match which we uh
assume could be quite close and uh it
just looked like he was going to win the
whole way through that um every match
has something to give you had the match
between the two Frenchmen and mvl was
also phenomenal calculating so good and
uh at the end there's Shack Shack one
when he needed to win so yeah some some
great chests today yeah I felt like
everyone who won their match uh maybe
other than Jack whose opponent put up
really Stern resistance sir they
deserved it Magnus just Supreme form
were used to that from by now mvl I
think he might be the Dark Horse for
this event it's such good form recently
and against the Fearsome opponent like
for Asia uh but yeah I can commiseration
is today I think out of those who lost
their match he was the most impressive
by far absolutely he really put up a big
a big fight in his magic and chakra but
I'm still thinking about the four Queen
position that we saw in the Maxi matchup
and as you pointed out David Maxim has
been on fire off late SCC going through
in the semifinals a close match against
Hikaru and his fantastic performance in
the total steel chess India as well
winning uh the whole event yeah and we
haven't even mentioned nepo as well I
mean nepo won so smoothly today we
thought that was going to be a very
close match but he dominated against
nishikiri as well so um looks like
there's a lot of players on good form
which is going to be very exciting I
think we're going to see some very tough
matches as as things develop so yeah
exciting we should mention naponiashi
and mamador if they played another
tournament earlier today they've been
playing chess all day long uh so to win
their matches to do it in style uh
impressive stuff
really impressive stuff and so much on
the line for these players fighting it
out for the tournament Victory to have
that spot into the Toronto Grand Final
for many of these players but these two
have already booked the ticket but this
was our Marquee matchup with Magnus
castle and Hikaru Nakamura the
celebrated rivalry the storyline
continued and for Hikaru Nakamura there
was no Revenge today as Magnus wrapped
it up in just three games he did make it
look easy today
yeah he did just uh taking his chances
when they came a bit of luck along the
way but you need that at this level
yeah I mean he just played fantastic
chess um I I think it sort that second
game was key uh Hikaru has some chances
there and he didn't grasp those
opportunities when he got them but uh
Magnus in great form nepo and great form
mvl in great form uh like everyone's a
great form so it's this it's gonna be a
great tournament
be a great tournament and as you pointed
out yeah taking on Anish Gary to Star
Wars of the game but this was the other
matchup that was wrapped up in just
three games David what went wrong for a
niche what does he need to switch up for
tomorrow for Anish he got a bit unlucky
in the first game he was hit by some
world-class preparation Napoli kind of
up to move 20s clearly still in book and
he just never stood a chance and after
that already done the match he just
couldn't fight back he took risks and
they uh did backfiring yeah I assume it
seemed like nepo's opening preparation
was just on point today uh he prepared
that first game uh pretty much all the
way to the end and uh well we know how
good he is so you could be it could be a
bit of a dark horse in that part you
know he needs to win this tournament to
qualify and uh he started very very
strong so yeah yeah and he's got a lot
of just action going on he's playing at
the lavitov event and then he comes and
fights it out and beats Anish in just
three games for me I think the matchup
of the day was Maxine vashir lagrav
against alireza farusha four exciting
battles it started with two draws but
the games were absolute fire on the
board in the third one again a roller
coaster Maxine vashilograph takes the
lead uh with the win in that and the
fourth game alireza had his big chance
his big moment with the black pieces but
an up and down top-sittery match saw
take the win with Four Queens on the
board absolute Madness yeah crazy match
there I mean you rarely see three queens
on the board let alone four so um that
that was a really exciting match and uh
if mvl keeps up is another guy another
guy he's gonna be really tough to beat
so uh lovely tactical chest today and I
just want to say accuracy levels through
the roof 93 and 90 in that match in such
crazy positions uh both players clearly
informed farooza is going to be one to
watch in the uh in the losers bracket
and there was this moment when Ali Raza
was making move with just two seconds on
the clock I think it was just amazing to
see him keep his composure in a wild
wild position and of course uh the last
match that we had we had one Armageddon
and it was this youngest participant of
the Champions chess star this season 16
year old Dennis lazovic taking on
shakria mamadarov who's making his debut
in division one while Dennis has made it
through to Toronto for shock it is all
about getting that tournament Victory
and he showed some confidence there a
very high accuracy rates there David
once again 96 for both players but in
the Armageddon it was a shock show yeah
he finally got the type of position he
thrives in mamajarov at the right moment
in the crunch game and he took the
victory but I mean 96 accuracy and you
still lose poor Dennis lazovic he must
be so frustrated right now yeah I mean
that's crazy accuracy uh all the way
through I mean this is only day one
they're warming up so uh it could yeah
it could be one of the highest accuracy
tournaments we we've ever seen so yeah
can be yeah warming up nicely dinosaurs
shark 96 percent accuracy for both these
players how does
it they're pretty good these players
it's uh yeah another lap is that point
one percent right that that was the win
right oh yeah that made all the
difference that just little percentage
so yeah
so much action so much drama so many
well shocking decisions today by uh
players the one that stands out to me
Hikaru in that game too against Magnus
Carlsen but of course uh this the action
does continue as we see
we will have we will have a replay of
the 2021 world championship match
tomorrow as Magnus takes on janapamnashi
and we also have a battle between two
extremely aggressive attackers Maxine
Bossier Legrand against chakra Muhammad
Yaro that is in the winner semi-final
but before that we'll see Hikaru battle
it out against Anish giri and we will
see a clash of the younger players with
alireza taking on Dennis last week David
which matchup stands out to you wow it's
like a three-course meal the this day of
Chess we're going to have tomorrow I'm
going to say Nakamura against giri
because the stakes are high Nakamura
will want to bounce back from that
defeat against Magnus and Anish giri
tournament Victory is essential for him
if he wants to qualify for the finals
I'm uh excited about that one I'm with
you there David as well I mean that
match is uh do or die I mean they're in
a position where they don't get second
chance but of course we can't forget he
caught I mean not Hikaru Magnus versus
nepo right I mean that is that's a big
well we'll have to see what kind of form
that pose in as well tomorrow I mean
he's got to play like he did today he's
got he's got in good Farm tomorrow
because we also saw the speed test
championship match where Magnus actually
I just annihilated Jana bom Nishi that
was a huge score that he won against so
for Jan he's got to make sure that he
switches things up as he takes on the
world uh number one tomorrow it's going
to be a big day of Chess and we've got a
big announcement as well as we are about
to reveal our winner of the puzzle of
the day and it is
a huge congratulations to cheetah who
did answer with the correct Rook A3 and
also gives us an explanation shital you
have won and Magnus Carlsen sign
Champions Chester t-shirt well done
there congratulations and we will have
more puzzles coming up tomorrow and more
chess action coming up tomorrow as well
as we go into day two the actions just
started and it promises to be a lot fun
we'll see you then
and that's it
we have a result wow
did it was it a dream have a result
really why I am shocked
Horror in a huge trouble
with the shake of his head resigns and
Magnus Carlson taking the match in just
three games
whoa what do we have a draw and it ends
in a draw we got an Armageddon with
checking out his opponent's camera there
and he sits back he sips his drink he's
breaking through Checkmate in one threat
with 27 Bishop takes E6 secondary threat
as uh you said Tanya it is game over
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]